visualizing and understanding huge
amounts of data has never been easier
thanks to tableau hi guys welcome to
this complete tableau tutorial by simply
learn in the next few hours we'll be
teaching you everything you need to know
about tableau in this video michelle
will take you through the basic concepts
of tableau then focus on use cases and
how you can work on the platform to get
the hands-on experience you need
then we'll take you through 30 important
interview questions that you might face
in a tableau interview before we begin
make sure you subscribe to our channel
and click on the bell icon to never miss
an update from simply learn hello and
welcome to tableau training for
beginners my name is michelle covine and
i'm with the simply learn team
today we'll be talking about all the
things you need to know to get started
with tableau so what is business
intelligence
companies use business intelligence
technologies to collect analyze and
present data in order to create
actionable information
today's businesses are always seeking
insights about their customers products
and services
so businesses are faced with many
questions such as how do i know my
customers are happy what would make my
customers stay and how can i increase
awareness of my products and services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers
there's also simple analytics built
right into tableau such as trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level tableau has
been a leader in the gartner magic
quadrant for the last six years and that
includes 2018. here we will take a look
at an overview of the products offered
by tableau so we have tableau desktop
which is where you do all of your
development this is where you connect to
and build visualizations and dashboards
today we'll be using tableau public
which is a free version of tableau
desktop but with some limitations such
as having no r integration and it can
only support up to a million rows of
data also any data published here is
made public so you can't use this for
private company information then there's
a new tool called tableau prep where you
can prepare your data by seeing it
visually before you connect and build
reports there's also tableau online
which is a cloud-hosted version of
tableau server a place where you can
publish your dashboards and it enables
you to share your dashboards in a secure
way tableau server has an option to be
on premises
so let's just do a quick comparison
between building a visualization in
excel and building one in tableau
okay so here we have an excel file full
of data that we will soon connect to and
use for some of our demonstration
purposes
and you can see that we have information
about orders if we wanted to find out
the quantity sold and the sum of sales
for each region we could do that by
creating a pivot table so we'll make it
i selected my cells we'll make it in a
new worksheet
and here we have the beginnings of a
pivot chart and we can grab region and
pull it into our columns
and then we'll grab
sales
and put it into values
and then we also want to look at
quantity i put that into values and it's
automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be some or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see
sales and quantity
one on top of the other and that's the
basics of a pivot chart now let's do a
similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns
and we get a similar thing maybe a
little nicer formatted and then we can
come and put quantity
there
and if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity
down in that box we also have this show
me dialog box which allows you to
see what visualizations you could build
using what's already on the screen or
the things that you have selected so
right now we could quickly switch it to
bar charts and now we can see quantity
and sales across our region with bar
charts or we could switch it to stacked
bars
and we can see our quantity across the
regions if you close that we can see our
legend over here and then our sales
across the region
so in tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization
so in summary we can see a side by side
of what we made using pivot tables in
excel and what we made in a similar
amount of time in tableau let's get
started with the tableau installation as
for requirements you need windows 7 or
later or you need your mac operating
system to be 10.11 or later here are
some of the browsers you can use to
install tableau we will be installing
tableau public today and to do that you
just google tableau public download and
click on that first link and then you
put in your email address and click
download the app so
let's just
look up tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now
it takes you to the tableau public page
where you can click sign in and create
an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file
that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open tableau public so let's go
take a look at the tableau public
opening page
so this is what tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to this is more limited in
tableau public than it is in tableau
desktop so if you invest in tableau
desktop you have
many many things you can connect to you
can also connect to data by clicking
this drop down connect data piece that's
especially useful when you've already
started your visualization
then we have the central portion called
open this is where anything that you
have opened up previously will show up
you can also click open from tableau
public and when you have my connections
timed out so i need to log in
but when you log in
it says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos um visualization of
the day
which is where people who have made
tableau public visualizations get
recognized for their skill and you get
some pretty cool ideas when you look
there
so let's get started
by connecting to data source we'll click
microsoft excel and we'll choose our
excel file and open it up and this is
our data source page this shows you the
sheets on the excel file and allows you
to drag them in so that you can see the
data show up this gives you a preview of
what your data will look like
you can see the tableau is starting to
classify our fields so anything that has
abc on it
shows that that's a column that has
strings in it we also have a globe which
is where tableau has recognized these
values to be geographical
so we have um state and it's recognized
that it contains states it bases it on
the keywords that it stores to identify
if it's geographical and so it takes a
look and you've named it city and it
knows that city is geographical we also
have the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row id that shows up with the
hashtag and i recognize that's a number
so now that we have our data source
pulled in we can come here and hit sheet
which is where you start to build your
visualization let's take a look at all
the different pieces of this before we
go any further we have the data that
we're connected to up here is our orders
sheet from the sample superstore excel
sheet we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the row
shelf where you can drag things in to
make changes happen in the visualization
center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here
a neat thing about show me is that when
you hover it'll tell you what types of
fields you need to build it so for a
symbol map try one geographical field
zero or more dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's what how you can
build a geographical symbol map
and when you're done with show me you
just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet one and sheet two a sheet
is basically just one visualization at a
time
let's get rid of the extra sheet we have
a dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called the story
which allows you to show
a sequence of visualizations so that you
can tell a story
perfect okay so we saw that tableau is
categorizing
our different fields and it is also
giving it a role
so we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure is sum by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see its four distinct
values as a dimension
and then we'll double click on quantity
and we can see the
numbers here the measures and you can
see here that it is the sum of quantity
and now we can also double click on
sales and we can see quantity and sales
to discuss a little bit more about
dimensions and measures you can see that
in general measures are numbers and
dimensions are not but sometimes like
row id it is a number now why would we
have a number up here instead of in the
measures so you can tell the difference
between number whether it should be in
measures or it should be in dimensions
based on whether you'll need to do any
calculations on it or if you would want
to be able to aggregate it at some time
so for
sales
if you have
several orders in a day
you might want to know what the sum of
those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they're on rows 2 3 4 and 5 you
might not want to know the sum of the
rows so tableau is smart enough that
when it sees id it knows that it belongs
up in the dimensions now you can switch
so if row id was actually something you
would want to aggregate for some reason
you can drag it down to the measures and
add it down there
but in our case row id isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green a little bit
different than what you might expect and
then we'll do sales so now we can see
over the different quantities what our
sales was it has been for this last this
period of time that we're looking at i
believe it's four years so for when
people bought three items the total
sales was
that number and you can see that this is
an axis so it's from 1 to 15. now if we
change it from continuous to discrete
you can see that 1 is a label 2 is a
label and it's not an axis ranging from
1 to it doesn't even have 15 because
there are no values under 15. these are
just individual labels so we go back
it's green again and you can see that
it's an axis so we have two greens on
here so we have two axes and change it
back to discrete and now we have one
axes and one set of individual labels so
let's go back to our sheet three
we have
all of these different
sales by the different quantity numbers
and up here we have our sorting when you
hover it tells you what kind of sorting
is going to happen so we could sort
quantity descending by sales so we can
see that when they buy three things we
have the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right clicking sort so we
could just sort
by descending or ascending or by sales
or
alphabetic
which is
not what we want
you can choose the field or you can
manually change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how tableau works let's go into a
little more detail
tableau is very much built on the
premise of drag and drop
so
let's build a simple visualization
and talk about what each of these
shelves and marks cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region
so we know we want
sales
on
let's do sales on
rows now for rows and for metrics since
this is continuous like we talked about
before it's making an axes
for our sales
we also can drag
region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
dimensions if you
pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying i want one
blank per column i want one region per
column so if you wanted to do it by
instead of region if you want to remove
something from a visualization you just
pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control z
tableau has the benefit of having
unlimited undos so let's say we wanted
to
bring on city let's say we want one
column per
city and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
city back off
i want one column per
region
and for
sales
i want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great now
let's say we want to adjust the color of
these bars you can click on color and
you can select any of them so let's pick
this nice blue or we can pick an orange
and that's how you can determine the
color
but if you want
something else to determine the color
you can take
region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale
so
if i want them to be
a different color based on sales and i
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous from light to dark
but for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great um
let's say we want to sort this
biggest to smallest
and we can look at size here so if we
want to adjust the size manually we can
click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on
sales we will drag sales onto size and
we can see that it gets bigger with
bigger sales we do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures
for label let's say we want the sales on
to label now we can see
the exact sales
number
for each
region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales for the
west region
you can adjust which one goes on top see
how we have two t's here those are both
labels
great uh two tip
when we click on tool tip it'll show us
what's going to happen
when we hover so as i hover here on east
it says region east sales and that shows
the sales amount
now we talked about
i'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average
of sales so we will right-click on our
sum of sales here in the rows hover over
measure um which right now is sum and
change it to average and we have a
different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the south
region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum i mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average
now we can see our average on the label
the label has some interesting
options
like you can format this and we could
say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue
and that happens right there
you can also choose to only show the
minimum and the maximum
this becomes handy on a line chart where
you don't want all marks labeled because
it gets very messy but you want the
tallest and the shortest part to be
labeled and maybe you just want the
tallest so we'll click label minimum
value and remove that checkbox and now
we just have the tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so
we could allow people
to look at this but only certain regions
so what we can do is we can come over to
region and right click on it and click
show filter and it will add it to that
filters card
and now we can remove central from the
mix and just look at those ones you see
if we remove south the new highest east
now has the label but if we put it back
in south will have the label again if we
don't want to have these filters
we can pull it off there or if we wanted
to filter out
by country oh we just have united states
so let's not filter by country
but we could pull in
category
and we have these filters by category
if we select them all
they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the south still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology
you can see the difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that i can mention
here
is that you can change the type of mark
manually so you saw when we pulled on
region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there
you can change it to be a lot of
different type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay
now let's
look at
building a scatter plot so scatter plot
is when you have a bunch of shapes and
points on a visualization with two axes
that are both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the
y-axis and we take discount and put it
on the x-axis we can see
our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount
and if we wanted to see this per order
we'll take order id and put it onto
detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order id and putting onto
detail
gives us all of these little points so
for each order what was our sales
and what was our discount so we have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly
let's actually do product id instead so
i'll put it right over top of order id
and it will replace it
now we see all of our products
anything that has high sales is up here
anything that has high discount is over
here you can see that it sort of has a
trend
where
things with high sales do not have high
discounts which makes sense if we wanted
to
know what
category these products i'll show up in
we could take category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show
just the dimension that you want to see
but it leaves the other ones in place so
for example if we click on furniture
first we have to turn on the highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization
and how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology we can see their
pattern which is a little bit different
so we have them by shape
with category let's drag category onto
color as well if you remember category
will determine the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items
they're all over here and most of the
things that are getting
high discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product id
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product id with
product name
and we see that that is a canon image
class advanced copier
so this copier is our big sales person
and
office supplies binders do not give us
very many sales and we're highly
discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so
let's say we wanted to know by
subcategory what our profit is like we
could grab
subcategory and pull it onto columns and
we would say we want one column per
subcategory
and then let's grab profit
and pull it onto rows
and you can quickly see
which categories
are profitable and which ones are not so
we can also take profit and put it onto
color
so that you can see that even more
clearly
right now it is going from orange to
blue which is tableau's default if we
wanted to change
from what color to what color it was
going we have a lot of options in here
when you go to edit colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here our subcategories here
but let's separate it out by category so
what i'm going to do i'm going to take
subcategory off
i'm going to put on category and that's
my category and then i'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory
so furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking out by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category
and we can click sort subcategory
descending by profit
and now what it does is within the
highest group within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so what we have here
is a quick view by category by
subcategory how we're doing on profit
we can see that
tables is our biggest drain on profit
and so if we wanted to improve the
profitability of furniture maybe we
would
not sell tables anymore it's just not
working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it
is you can see that there's some of
these words are getting cut off so
we can right click on this axis and
click
rotate label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to
profit by
sub category
then it names the title up here so this
is making it look a little bit better
and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit and click format and you can see
that we can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and
we can do it currency by the thousands
and we can get rid of these decimal
places and now you can see it's just a
little bit nicer a little bit more clear
maybe we don't have to have the label
here that says
category subcategory so we can hide
field labels for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in tableau
is one of those things where there are
just a lot of different ways you could
change things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are
building these visualizations if you
want to
have access to this data set so that you
can build along with me just make a
comment in the comments below and the
simply learn team will send you this
data set now we're going to take a look
at creating a hierarchy in tableau
so we'll make a new tab
and we're going to make a sheet
called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at
sales as a number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products
names so it's going to make sure that
you really want to do this i'm going to
click add all members and now we can see
all of our products and their sales
over all time
so if we sort this we can see our
highest sale selling item which we
discovered earlier as the advanced
copier and we scroll down to the bottom
our lowest selling items
so we have our products and we can group
that by sub category
and you can see i need to put it in the
front again
and by category
all right i'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so
a product rolls up into a subcategory
which rolls up into a category you can
create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory
let's do the same thing by grabbing
the product name and putting it
underneath subcategory so now it knows
categories the parent then there's
subcategory and then there's product
name this allows you to instead of
pulling this off
or putting it back on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales
by category by subcategory by product
name this is really useful when you're
creating a detail section for your users
and so when somebody wants to know
let's say you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
show filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like i see technology has the
highest sales and i just want to see
technology so i'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so i
just have technology will i want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it
up phones phones does so i just actually
want to look at phones so i'm going to
remove accessories copiers and machines
and what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now i can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization
let's give this visualization a little
more depth
first i'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly
so what we can do
is take
sales and drag it onto color
let's change our marks to a square and
now it's going to color each of these
it colors every one of these cells based
on its darkness for sales this is a
little bit heavy of a color you can
click color here and change the opacity
to give it a little bit
of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the west seems to have the highest
sales
and that technology in the east is the
very highest so now when we
drill into subcategory it keeps that
coloring and we can see more in depth
and quicker that phones has the highest
across most of them it's not quite the
highest in the west because chairs is
the highest in the west
there's one place in tableau where
hierarchies are built in and that's in
dates so dates in tableau can be very
complex because they allow
very complex visualizations so we will
not go into depth about dates at this
time but let's take a look at how they
work for hierarchies so we have order
date that we can pull onto columns here
and you can see that it's blue meaning
that it's discrete so each one of these
is a header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag
profit
onto rows
so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when i click this
plus on
columns it'll split it out into quarters
so this is a header and these are all
sub headers underneath that header
because it is distinct um and discrete
right now instead of continuous so it's
split out year year year year and
quarters quarters quarters quarters this
allows you to quickly compare quarter
one across all of the years and quarter
two across all the years and quarter
four across all the years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking
maybe category and pulling out a color
and now we have one line for each
category and we can see that a drop in
technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter 2 of
2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see of repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when i change
it to a bottom one year same thing same
here it changes it to be green and now
it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when i
press the plus and then changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going
and drill down to month
you can go pretty far
now when we add category as color we get
our three lines for the three categories
and we also have highlighting turned on
here still so when we click on
technology we can highlight technology
with the others in the background so we
don't lose the context of the other
categories
let's take that back off
next let us talk about calculated fields
so we'll make a new sheet and we're
going to create our first calculated
field we can create a calculated field
by clicking this arrow
which gives us some options and clicking
create calculated field or we can come
and click in the white space below
dimensions or below measures and we
right click and click create calculated
field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or
values you can use or you can come and
drag it in so if we want profit and we
want sales if we do profit divided by
sales that is
a profit ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate
and that will duplicate our field but i
just want to start over again so i'll
click create calculated field
and i will call it profit
ratio
aggregated
and in this one we're going to do sum
click
of profit
click divided by
sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio on
aggregated how will those behave
differently in tableau let's look at
this by looking at a single
order so first let's bring on all the
orders and all the products
under that order and let's look at this
order
so
i want to filter this whole dashboard to
only this order so i can right click on
it and click keep only that creates a
filter up here
that only has that box checked
and if i want to get rid of this later
i can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but i want
to so
keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated i double clicked on it
and i added it here
and profit ratio unaggregated again
double clicking another side by side
let's give us a little bit more room
so when i dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side and the entire titles okay so i
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and i brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now
so when we're looking at it without any
aggregation these two calculations are
the same profit ratio aggregated let's
look at that again we'll click edit and
that's the one where we sum profit and
some sales before we divide and then
we've got profit ratio unaggregated so
let's also look at profit and look at
sales this is a technique that i use
when i'm trying to understand how my
calculated fields are working try to
break it down to the lowest level
possible and see if it's doing what i
expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at
0.5 or 50 percent and that's because
profit is 8 and sales is 16. for adam's
telephone messaging
now let's take off product name
when we take off product name we can see
that they start to vary we've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller
so if we take profit at 219
and divided by sales at 508.6
we get
0.4 not 1.8 so where does this 1.8 come
from
well let's put product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however
does the calculation profit divided by
sales and then
sums it afterwards you can see it right
here it's the sum of profit ratio on
aggregated so it makes this calculation
and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5
and that's where we get our 1.8 which is
what we see
when we pull off product name 1.8 so for
most calculations you want to do profit
ratio aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region
now let's say we also wanted to see
each region
by sales per customer so let's create
some calculated fields that will help us
do that let's create our first
calculated field
that's going to get us a count of
customers
let's call it total
number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer id let's do
count distinct
of customer id and that gives us the
total number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it
sales per
customer
so we're going to do our sum
of sales
which we can drag in
and divide that by
total number of customers now you see
that calculated field we just made pops
up inside of our
calculation
dialog box and we hit apply
and it shows up so we hit ok and let's
replace
total number of customers
with
sales per customer and now we can see
our sales per customer ratio and which
ones have the highest or for this next
part i'm going to make a couple of
visualizations in a row that all applied
to the same information using a couple
of different tactics so
first
let's use show me so i want to look at
region and sales for this visualization
so i'm going to control click
region
after i clicked sales so one more time
i'm going to
click on sales and i'm going to control
click region
and i'm going to click show me and it's
going to give me all of the different
visualizations i could make with region
and sales let's pick tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales
by region
and we have the size and the color of
the box is both sales so let's say we
wanted the size to be sales but the
color to be profit so let's grab profit
and drag that on to sales so now we can
see our most profitable to our least
profitable let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to advanced and
make the center number
zero
this means that it will never be red
unless it's less than zero so let's hit
apply so it's all blue and if anything
ever goes negative then it will be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales
profit by region
perfect
now we're going to start using our
geographical
fields so we have state city country and
postal code let's double click on state
and see what happens
awesome so it is
generated these two fields tableau has
generated longitude and latitude for us
and it's been able to recognize the
states in the united states and where
they're located and given it a longitude
and latitude
so next we will
look at sales
by state by double clicking on sales and
what it's done was change the size of
the dot based on sales now i think i'm
going to move sales from size to color
and it has automatically changed it to a
filled map instead of dots on a map
perfect so now we can see the states
with the
biggest amount of sales let's put it
back onto size and we have our circles
again
let's put sales on the size not stayed
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the builder okay
so we have size for
sales again and for profit on to color
again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable
or less than zero in this case is orange
let's do what we did with color before
change it to
red blue diverging and set our center
point to zero okay so now we know that
if anything is red it was negative in
profit perfect let's name this sheet
sales
profit
by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so
this is when we drag something to the
columns shelf just remember we want one
column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what i want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and technology
now let's
take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart
by clicking on its appropriate marks
card so if we want to change them both
we can click on all
and change them both to maybe circles
and you can see how they go up and down
but if we want to just change
one of them let's put those back to
automatic we'll go to profit and change
that one to
the circles so now we can see
those profit numbers and if we want them
to be overlaid on the same area we would
right click on profit the second measure
on the rows and click dual axis so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space one of them is a bar chart
and one of them is a bubble chart and we
can see our sales versus our profit at
least they're not the same amount of
dollars obviously but we can see a
higher
sales and a higher profit we also have
medium sales and a medium profit we have
a medium sales but a really low profit
and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet
as
sales
profit
by category
and
finally we're going to make our details
sheet so we're going to go down to
subcategory level and bring it onto rows
and remember subcategory can expand out
to the actual products let's bring that
back in and we're going to bring sales
onto columns which makes us a sales bar
chart and profit onto columns which
makes us a profit bar chart now let's
color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color
now sales is colored by sales we'll do
the same thing here we did before we'll
go red blue diverging
[Music]
and make the center
zero we actually don't have to do that
for sales because sales will never be
negative but it's pretty important for
profit so we'll go to the profit marks
card and take profit onto color
and do the same thing there
we have red blue diverging
advanced center is zero great
so now if it's negative it will be there
so let's sort this
by profit and so both of them have
sorted with profit in mind and we can
easily see our subcategories that have a
negative profit
rename this and we'll call it our
details sheet
so now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do with similar
information
i think i want these bigger on the
states so we'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have
information over here that shows you
what sheets you can bring on these get a
little bit more complex so they'll be
covered in more in-depth type of videos
and then we have our size so
we could make a range of sizes based on
maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size
and we're going to make it
by
a thousand and this is our
dashboard size so let's bring on sales
profit by region
sales and profit by state now a map
needs a little bit more horizontal space
than region does let's bring sales and
profit by category underneath the region
and the detail underneath the state give
our map more space again perfect
now tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if i click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
i just want to look at the south and i
click on south it zooms into all my
south states now my categories have
updated to be just the south ones and my
details have updated as well so
we could see that central has pretty big
sales you know bigger than the south but
the profit is lower than the south so we
can click on central and focus on
central
let's use
that uses filter
on all three of these
dashboards that lead us up to the detail
so building a quick dashboard like this
let's make this taller would allow you
to do some sort of analysis such as
let's take a look at central because
they have relatively high profits but
low sales so we click on central and
then we see oh man texas is having a
really hard time so let's click on texas
and now we're seeing in texas that we
have negative profit in these categories
so we can control click on furniture and
office supplies and we can see all of
our products that are really just
killing us in texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you
back out of that subcategory section you
can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet
and let's make a quick visualization
that will apply our parameters and our
sets too
so let's take a look at all of our
customers by their sales and let's sort
customer name descending by sales great
so now we're going to make a parameter
that will allow the user of the
dashboard to choose how many customers
they want to see how many of our top
customers that they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make it an integer
and we're going to give them the option
to choose the number of customers within
a range our low is going to be 5 so
we'll let them see 5
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of 5. let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10.
okay so now if you want to see how this
parameter looks you can come down to
parameters before we only had dimensions
and measures on the left side of our
tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
the parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allowed them to go down to five
and
up to
20 with steps of five
great
now we're going to create a set a set is
a custom field that defines a subset of
data based on some conditions so the set
we're going to build is going to be
based on customer name so when you right
click on customer name you can come down
and click create hover on create and
create a set with so far when we created
a parameter and a calculated field you
clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and
customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
defined by the parameter
by sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10 we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here
for it to be defined by and it's sales
and we want it to be by sum of sales
if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers buy average profit
but we want sales and some
okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it on to rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10
and let's grab the set and drag it onto
our filters so now we have filtered the
data down to our top 10. if this were
applied to a dashboard this would allow
the end user to see the top 10 quickly
and then maybe expand it out to the top
20 if they're interested in that
information now let's move on to
creating a donut chart so a donut chart
is basically a pie chart with a white
center so let's start by building a pie
chart which in tableau is pretty easy
especially if you use show me so let's
create a pie chart for each category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're going to control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click
pie and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one pie for each
region we can take region and drag that
onto columns so we have one column for
each region and then one pi for each of
them you can see that the pi varies in
size based on sales as well as the angle
is for sales so east has more sales in
general than south
and this helps you to see that
technology
has smaller sales in the south than it
does in the east so i recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of
size and now we have all of our pie
charts the same size now we're going to
make what's called a dual axis chart and
to make a dual axis chart we have to
have two axes so let's grab
number of records and we'll grab it and
drag it to rows and we will change it
from sum to minimum and that's because
every record will have a minimum number
of rows of one and then they all end up
on the same axis great and now we're
going to make a second number of records
by minimum and we can do that by doing
those steps again by dragging number of
records up here and changing it to
minimum again or a quick trick that i
can show you is if you want to
duplicate anything you have on the chart
here you can just hit control and then
click and drag it and it will duplicate
it so if you wanted your number of
records to also be down here onto your
details or on your labels you can
control click it and then leave it there
great so now we have our two axes and we
have our two marks cards that each
affect their own
set of visualizations so let's go to
this top one affects these so let's show
that by changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to
circle so now each of these are a circle
let's take category off of color and we
can take some of sales off of detail and
let's change the color to white
and now we're going to put this white
circle on top of our pie chart by
clicking here on our second measure
and clicking dual axis and now it's got
them lined up one on top of the other
and we have our donut chart so if we
want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our inner circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one doughnut chart for
each region and if we wanted to take
this header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here
you can come and edit that by clicking
on label and changing its alignment so
let's put it in the middle
perfect so now we can see
our header here so we don't need it down
here anymore you can right click and
click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies
so to get how the number of sales here
for each of them let's go to
remember our pie marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie
can tell you how much sales they have if
you take the sales here that's on label
right click and click format we can
change that to currency
and let's get rid of our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with central so we
go back to affecting our circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four doughnut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers
for each segment and also for the donut
as a whole you can also change the
colors the tableau selects for each
slice by coming to the marks card that
has color for the pie so category color
and clicking edit colors and you could
change it to any of these automatic ones
where if you double click on one it
gives you all of the options for colors
that you could possibly want there's
also several different palettes you
could choose from so let's say we like
this one and you can just click assign
palette and it will grab those off of
there those look very similar to what we
have already so i'm going to pick a
different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes and you fit your business a
little bit more
specifically
perfect let's say
we make our
pies bigger
crease that size
and we'll also increase the center size
oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show
two pie charts at the same time um or a
pie chart that's kind of split up by
different categories this has been
available in some other tools and
tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our
generic
category by sales so with control click
sales we come over to show me and click
pie and it makes our pie for us it
remembers the colors that you have
determined
in other pages so that's a nice feature
again let's make it entire view so we
can see our pi nice and big and now
we're going to
create our dual axis again so we grab
number of records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes and let's come to
our top one
and make it bigger
that affected both of them because we
still have sales on size
for both of them
so sales is affecting the size of the
pie chart as well as the size of the
angles so let's take sales off of size
for both of them
and make the second pie chart a little
smaller perfect now let's also affect
our second pie chart by having the color
defined by region instead of defined by
sales let's talk about how i'm replacing
it with region so you could change the
color by dragging region onto color and
that replaces it or let's go back and we
can drag region right on top of the
thing we're trying to replace and it
will replace it there great so now we
have the smaller circle that's going to
go on top split up by region with the
angle defined by sales and the category
is on the top one with the angle defined
by sales let's pick some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for
category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to i'm just gonna keep following
this write down
apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner pie
separate from the outer pie
maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger
like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
that change that zero line to none
perfect get rid of some of the clutter
on this visualization i still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have min number of records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come tool tip right as
you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase
mid number of records i erased too much
you need to leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
min number of records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen
these visualizations are a little bit
more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so i recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below and
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have
at this point in the presentation we're
going to put together some dashboards so
first let's build our worksheets for
this dashboard we're going to build a
worksheet
called
sales by
year which adds the name up here and
we're going to
take our order date and drag it onto
columns and now we want this to be a
continuous axis so we're going to change
it to our continuous year and now we
have an axis and we're going to look at
sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto
labels and if we want to have different
color lines for each region for example
we can drag region onto color
and that splits our lines up
into the different regions and gives us
a legend over here perfect now we're
going to duplicate this sheet by right
clicking down here and clicking
duplicate now we have sales by year two
let's rename it to
profit
by year
and then let's drag profit right over
top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
some of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our axis
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like
right click here
go format and we'll change our numbers
to
currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars
one thing you can do in tableau is let's
undo that
since
sales is going to be dollars pretty much
everywhere we use it we can define our
default property for these numbers so
when we right click on the measure here
you can go to default properties and you
have the options to change the defaults
for any of these things and we're going
to change our number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit ok and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined
it to be formatted differently so we
could still define it to be different
here on this sheet than it is on any
other sheet
let's do the same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this
our
overall dashboard
change
our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine i think it fits nicely
on the laptops that i use and that is
used by most of our customers now let's
drag sales by year now watch what
happens when i drag it on here it brings
sales by year but it also brings the
legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on central and you
see it highlights central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit ok
and then right click on category and
click show filter so now it is over here
and we're going to do
a similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here
so now we have
a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
now so when we go to overall
we can come to our
drop down here more options
hover over filters
and you can see category now here's an
interesting thing that we'll see
even though we have a category filter on
both charts when i take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be
that's because we have two different
filters for category one on the sales
worksheet and one on the profit by year
worksheet i'll show that
by clicking here
going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so
let's back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year now we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to
the profit by year
sheet
you can see that it now has category on
there let's go to overall let's come
here
filters category and now we have a
filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now
you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do
a couple more filters so we can do by
category
let them filter out regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is
apply to worksheets
selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them
change their
time selection so this one's a little
bit different since we've already
determined that we wanted year and we
wanted it to be continuous filters for
continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for
these
discrete fields and that's because
continuous fields are a range instead of
just a list so we don't list out a
continuous field we make a range for it
so we've already defined that we want it
to be continuous year and if i come over
here
and click on right click order date and
click show filter it's doing discrete
year by default
so
remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at
let's come up here to year that's
already marked as continuous and click
show filter and now it is year
but it's based on a range and we have
this slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization
let me show you a trick to make this
apply to both not a trick but just if
you have not applied it to both
worksheets but you already added it to
the visualization see it's here but it's
only affecting one worksheet you can
change
the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to
the worksheet where the filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by
each of the regions we can do that as
well so let's go back to our sales sheet
as a quick tip you can go to the sheet
by clicking this go to sheet button here
or here
in the event that you want to go to a
sheet but you don't want to scroll back
and forth to find where it is so go to
sheet now we're going to do a dual
access chart again like we showed
earlier and i'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by
if i change the opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the rows section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top i can see this
versus this now if we wanted to on hover
show that this is overall sales we can
click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put
oh we don't want it to be orange let's
make it black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it um a
little bit more of a color that'll stand
out just a little darker than the others
perhaps
so when we go back to our work alright
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for profit by year
go to sheet and
control
drag
release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not orange
overall profit
okay
and right click
dual access
there we go now i forgot to do one thing
on the last dashboard when you make a
dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
sync up these axes and so this axis over
here is for the overall line and this
axis over here is for the region line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should edit our axes
and instead of calling it just profit
over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit
by region just so that it's clear which
axis goes to the which one
or you can come here and click
synchronize axes so it's very clear that
this is much bigger than these
and if you synchronize the axes let's go
back before we named him
okay synchronize the axis then we don't
need both of these headers so we can
come here and click show header and we
just have the one let's do the same
thing on sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind
when we do
filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
if we filter to 2
then it's only the sum of those two
so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered um why does
this happen
why doesn't this line always show the
total no matter what you select here
well that's because this filter applies
to
the whole dashboard so it filters this
line to those regions just as much as it
filters these lines
so i'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so
let's do it using show me we'll click on
region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click pi let's close it
again great so now we have the sales by
region pi we'll make it the entire view
and when you hover you can see that it's
showing us sales in dollar amounts now
it would be
more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole
at 100
so let's come here to our slice size
we'll right click on it and we're going
to use what's called a quick table
calculation
and change it to percent of total so now
when you hover you can see that the west
is 31
of the pie
great
let's also label each of these slices so
i'm going to control click and drag
region onto label and add region to the
labels i'm going to undo that and show
you what would happen if i just dragged
region onto labels without copying it
without holding control it will move it
and get rid of our colors and we don't
want that so we're going to control and
drag another way to do this let's go
back is by taking region and dragging it
onto label just straight from over here
but in this case for the sum of sales
where we've applied the quick table
calculation we want that quick table
calculation to also show up in our label
so i'm going to control and drag and it
brings that quick table calculation
along with it if i were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and i'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead ctrl and drag
that's probably one of my very favorite
tableau tricks great now let's add a
filter for region so i'm going to right
click here and click show filter and we
will make sure that this gets added to
all of our sheets once we've made them
all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet
sales by state
let's do a map
great so um one way to get your map
started is to double click on any of
these dimensions that have a globe next
to them so since we want to go with
state we can double click on state and
it starts mapping out state so what it
does is it adds latitude and longitude
to our rows and columns that are
generated here
and another way to get going so let's go
back is to click on the geographic part
you want
and then control click on sales like we
did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
going to do a field map
click on that so now we have our field
map based on state
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label
and you can see we have the dollar sign
and the money formatting that we made
earlier and let's control and drag state
onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here
on the ellipses
and edit it there so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there i think i lost my
center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think
great okay so now you can see that it
puts the state on top you can also see
in some of these places where they're
super close together that you can't see
all of the state's labels and that's
because
this option here in labels is unchecked
allow labels to overlap other marks so
tableau senses when the marks are too
close together and it's gonna become too
hard to read and we'll hide anything
that overlaps with each other if we
click this option now you see everything
but it gets a little crowded over here
so let's unselect that and you'll be
able to see what the sales are upon
hover
great now we have our sales by state
for filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters um so now we
could uh the lowest amount for a state
is 920
for sales for this time period and we
could filter out ones that have sales
lower than that but
i think this isn't what i want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
state show filter great so now we could
filter out a state we could just show
arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization
new sheet
rename it to be called sales by
sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategory we could
either drag on subcategory here or
because of our hierarchy press plus now
we have subcategory and category and
let's bring on sales it's defaulting to
this bar chart which is perfect that's
what i want and now we could color it by
subcategory
and this is a discrete coloring we could
also color it by
sales
and this is a continuous coloring so
the darkest corresponds with the height
now we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to add to
the distinction between the different
categories so that's very clear
where they start and stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for subcategory so let's
bring on
category as our filter so we'll right
click here click show filter there's
category and let's do a filter for
our date so we're going to come here to
order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit ok right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard
our sales dashboard and
change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the legends
and the filter so last time we created
the filters after we built the dashboard
but this time you can see that the
filter
gets brought in when we brought in the
dashboard let's do our sales by state
side by side here and let's do sales by
subcategory underneath so i dragged it
you can see how i pull it towards the
bottom of the dashboard and it kind of
fills in the space where it's going to
be
and then brings it in so now it's
brought in all our filters and all of
our legends it defaults to putting the
filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
going to make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and
a lot of resizing to get things the way
you want them to be give our map more
room
and we have a mixture over here of
legends and
filters let's move our legends out of
there so we can grab this legend and
come and put it on this side
and this legend come put it over here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this legend goes up here with this one
i'm going to actually click here and
change it from a tiled so right here it
says tiled object to a floating object
that lets it sit on top of a
visualization i'm going to put it on top
of this visualization right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one
circle there's no size comparison so
it's not like we have several circles
and we have to look and see which one's
the biggest so that we can tell the the
amount of sales so we don't need this
legend and we can just remove it from
the dashboard let's clean up some of
these we have several different versions
of what your filters could look like so
my personal favorite is multiple values
drop down it gives you some of the most
flexibility but if you wanted them to
only be able to select a single value
you could turn it into a radio button
list so that it's a selected all or it's
one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so
let's do
multiple value drop downs
for big ones like state there is the
option
of searching so i know i want utah and i
search and there's utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard hit okay
we'll do this again
[Music]
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe um a total number up here at
the top that you just wanted to stay the
same all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters okay great so
we can change what region we're looking
at by
selecting central here and then we're
just looking at central throughout all
the visualizations i love looking at it
on a map and seeing just one at a time
it just really makes the region name
just stand out to you but if we wanted
to use this as our filter to filter the
rest of the dashboards we can click this
uses filter button and now when we click
on central here it stays in context here
but the other two dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only 170 thousand dollars and
texas becomes the darkest on the
visualization
there are some ways you can change that
but if you're wondering why do my colors
look a little differently when i filter
that's why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at texas we click this this updates to
just central this updates to just texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say
let me scroll down a bit storage now
everything updates to storage it's
interesting i wouldn't have known very
quickly that there are some states that
didn't have any storage sales but now
when we click on storage we can tell i
showed you before that you can control
click and look at binders and storage
and it puts those two together also in
tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
i don't know what's up with wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and
let's get started on our next one our
next dashboard is going to be the profit
version of this dashboard so some of
these visualizations we can use again so
let's go to sales by region right click
and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
i mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere
that sales is used you have to replace
it with profit i'm also going to drag
this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall then the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
circle and onto the text now when i
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in
a region filter and this one no longer
has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what i want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier tableau will
not allow you to make worksheet that has
the same name as another worksheet you
can
call it number one or since it does put
the title up here you can put an extra
space at the end or it does detect that
space it counts it as a different title
even though it's the same title just
with a space that does cause some issues
so like when we're looking here and
we're saying oh profit by subcategory i
want that oh this is when we made it but
you don't want this one you want this
one and it gets a little confusing the
nice thing is when you're dragging
things onto your dashboard when you
hover you should get a little picture
here of what dashboard what
visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all of these called sheet 5 sheet 7
you won't know exactly what that is
right away so that little preview is
very helpful great profit by subcategory
we'll do the same thing by removing out
all our filters so i just click on it
and hit delete and affects these so
control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on
category as a filter okay
show filter there we are
and let's do our order date filter right
now order date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you can just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so i'll rename this and call it
profit
over time
by category
so we're going to
bring on our order date into columns and
it goes to our discrete value let's
change it to our continuous value so we
get the axis let's grab our profit onto
rows and it makes us a line chart we're
going to change that to an area chart an
area chart is nice because when you
split it up by category by dragging
category onto color you can now see
what category is responsible for how
much profit like you do with a line
chart however its area is what defines
that so you can see that area over time
and do comparisons and also it stacks
them on top of each other so that you
can tell that for 2013 our profit was
around fifty thousand dollars really
quickly otherwise we have to add that
line this line here and it makes these
lines smaller and lower um more
difficult to see so
back to our profit over time by category
so that's some of the benefits of having
an area chart and if we wanted to go a
little more detailed than here you hit
this plus and now we have over quarter
we have some negative profits that's
interesting but let's go back to every
the year great and for this one we're
going to make one more pie chart so we
could start from scratch or we could
duplicate our profit by region pie chart
which i'm going to do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on
tooltips will affect your level of
detail in the visualization here when
it's on tool tips sometimes it won't
change the level of detail but it could
have an effect on like so if we brought
oh let's do this right now so right now
the level of detail of this chart does
not go to the category by
region like it did before you can bring
it on to detail here and it won't affect
color and it won't affect labels but it
will change the detail and you see how
it splits it out again this is what it
would look like if it's by region by
category and you have much more slices
to this pie we'll go back but if we take
region and put it onto tooltip it's not
at a low enough level for that tool tip
to make any sense so it's going to put
that star you see region is star that's
because this section of the pi covers
multiple regions if we filtered the
region to just central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when
at all levels it doesn't make any sense
but we won't leave it there
excellent so you can see how the color
is what determines
is a big part of what determines how
many slices you get the level of detail
for the whole chart is a big factor as
well on how many slices you get great
profit by region profit by category by
subcategory and by
profit over time and we have
our category filter we don't have our
subcategory filter yet we grabbed
category but let's right click on
subcategory and click show filter there
we go now we have a filter for category
and subcategory
here's our region one
we have region in two places and we
don't want that
we wanted to apply to all of them we'll
do that when we get to the dashboard
and
we have category year of order date and
subcategory great those are all the
filters i wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once i get it set
to the size i want
profit we'll start with profit by
region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that
some different space have this at the
bottom
have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up
next to it so let's again drag it over
to the side it's always good to pay
attention to the highlighted section and
it gives you kind of an idea oh you see
i accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when i grabbed this i didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all of
these and they happen to be inside the
same section you can come and click
select a layout container and now i'm
grabbing all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what i'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area i'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category
legend applies to both this chart and
this chart so that's very nice and the
subcategory legend i won't make floating
i'll just put here by subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give
our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now um because i didn't have
to on
this chart and this chart change profit
to dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
i recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so i like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so i take it the
second to the top and i drag the top one
down and then um category above
subcategory
just for logical sense excellent and we
have our profit dashboard let's see
there is this check box down here called
show dashboard title so if we wanted to
have the title at the top here you can
click that button any floating objects
don't shift down
like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title
that's up to you excellent so at this
point we have our overall dashboard that
looks at sales and profit we have our
sales dashboard and we have our profit
dashboard our profit dashboard isn't 100
complete because i forgot to make sure
all of these filters apply to all of
these worksheets so let's go ahead and
do that right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook
and you can see the rest here so if you
wanted all on the dashboard and you
wanted this one or something like that
then you have the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
you filter to just one
year this area chart becomes a lot less
useful but if you're looking at two or
more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard
to our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action
so you can make an action
on
a worksheet
you can see right here
actions or on a dashboard actions so
since we're linking between two
dashboards this is going to be a
dashboard action
sorry just trying to un-highlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made and you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and define an action it
was made by
clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action or when we look on
our sales dashboard we clicked on this
uses filter button so we should have
several actions here that were all
generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions
when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use this filter a highlight
action that we can see from here in
region and go to url action that we
haven't used if you have any questions
about go to url please post them in the
comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a url here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in a url
here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
url that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information it can get pretty cool
okay but we want to
link from this dashboard to one of our
other dashboards and you actually do
that using a filter action so we're
going to name that action go
to
sales dashboard
and we want it to happen when we click
on our sales sheet so you see right here
it shows us the two sheets that are on
this dashboard when we click on the
profits dashboard we don't want this
action to occur this is our go to sales
dashboard now you can have an action
occur on hover
or select you've seen select happen
that's what our filter uses filter
actions use and on menu so we're going
to do it on menu
and
the targeted sheets it defaults to this
dashboard saying when i click on this i
want the rest of this dashboard to
update but instead it's going to take us
to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this i want these
sheets to update
now
we're going to define what filters it's
going to apply by default it's going to
apply all of the filters based on what
we click so if we click here it will
filter to just 2013 let's say we click
here it will filter to just 2013 and it
will filter to the region we selected
so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay
now when i click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and west go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now
so
we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here
go to sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now
that happens because
it's trying to pass region information
to that dashboard
but this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select what fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and let me go back to that
we click to order date year and it goes
to the target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this
okay and we're gonna add one more
we're gonna add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay if um
one dashboard has region in it and the
other dashboard doesn't have region in
it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard
what if
we
take out region
remove region and we're just doing it
based on year
okay okay
click here go to sales dashboard and
there everything is
so now it will filter back to the year
that you selected so this is all 2013
but it will not filter to the region you
selected
so even when we come here and we select
west
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to west
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to
sales
let's make one for profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing
where it's only going to filter it to
the year now you can see oh i started to
type in i didn't show you this before
but you can
search text so i started typing in year
and it shows you that under order date
you have all these different options in
this dashboard right now if you remember
we're using the continuous one that is
marked by
the little calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just trading it like a
discrete field
okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do
is for west here we can select
both years i'm i'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click
go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could put a note in the tooltip for
this that this doesn't work for
region linking from this area it doesn't
work or perhaps
you could not have this total line on
the same visualization you could have a
separate visualization that shows the
total or an area chart instead and that
will let you not have this problem of go
to sales dashboard not linking
appropriately
so now we're going to create our final
dashboard our segment dashboard and it's
going to use
a parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit
and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or ok and there it
goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same
if we go forward again segment analysis
and profit and sales by segment that
allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make
a profit in sales it's going to be a
bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet
consumer corporate and home office and
then we're going to look at it segment
and we're going to make a matrix with
category and we get to fill in this
space with our
visualizations so we're going to do
sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
it's nice and easy when the two marks
cards are based on a different measure
to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on
a bar chart now if we had profit in
front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales
another way you can fix it
say you wanted the profit access to over
here for some reason you can right click
on the axis and put mark type or oh move
marks to front
another way to change it we don't need
both of these
so let's not show that header and we
don't need this to be labeled profit
because it's for both of them so the way
you get rid of that is actually you
click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title
and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes
and we have three sets of bar charts
across excellent the next chart we're
going to build oh so right now they are
it automatically added the colors based
on measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them's named profit
one of them's name sales and we know
that you can come here click color and
hit edit colors and it will open this
dialog box but you can also come here
and double click on a color pops open
that dialog box let's pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20
let's pick colors from this palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever when you make it more opaque
you start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
so stick with the tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top
customers
by sales and this is where we're going
to use our parameter where we made our
top end customers so
let's bring in
our sum of sales make a bar chart for
that and then we're also going to we're
bringing in our set now so we have our
in and our out we're going to break up
our set
by our segment as it's part of our
segment analysis and we'll bring in our
customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for
our users of this dashboard they're like
in and out of top end customers by sales
maybe we want this to say something a
little bit more user-friendly so let's
make a calculated field and we're gonna
call it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if
and we're going to use our set top end
customers by sales and since it's an in
their outset it treats this like
if it's in top end customers by sales
then
top
we're going to um do with string so it's
going to be top and then we want to use
the number that's in our parameter so we
have to convert it from a number to a
string and we have to concatenate them
together in tableau you can use a plus
sign top and always make sure you have
space between what you're concatenating
together that's something that i tend to
forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in the set then top blank
customers
else if it's not in the set we will just
call it other and in tableau you always
need to end your if statement with an
end here it tells us our calculation is
valid while we're here i want to show
you a little trick there's this arrow
button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau
and it even sorts it out by different
categories so if we didn't know how to
make this into a string we could go to
type conversion we could click on string
and it gives you an example also when
you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then i clicked on string and
i'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of tableau also in tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press dash
or
slash slash and type in
this is a more user friendly
title hit ok and there we go we have our
more user-friendly title we drag it here
we see our top 20 customers and other
and we don't want to show this anymore
but we still want it in place you can
click right click on it up here and
click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it
our top customers by sales but it's
interesting to know profit as well so we
have really big sales but how is their
profit doing so let's drive profit onto
color
and you can see this person has a
negative amount of profit despite their
big sales so that's important for us to
know and we can change our color like we
did previously to go from red to blue
and we can change our center to zero
and now we can see the negatives really
quickly
now they're not the only one neither
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to
show in or out we just are going to
allow them to show how many but we do
want to be able to have them filter by
category so let's show that filter and
by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen it is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its legend and total customers
by sale and it pops up with its legends
and filters and it pops up with its
parameter now we're going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are
workbook wide meaning that it's going to
exist over here too
uh it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if i i've changed it to 10
and if i come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why i should name my sheets
let's see if i can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in sheet 13
we have our top 10. so i've got a 10 and
i've got a 10 over there and if i change
it to 20
and i go back to my segment dashboard
it is also changed to 20. so it will
affect all sheets always very important
to know great so here's our
visualization
here are some of the more useful legends
so
let's
make this floating and put it over by
the visualization it matters for we can
do the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these affect
all the dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter
it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole
workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select
number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating legends
and this is a little bit more
user-friendly
than the title we made for the
developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
now let's discuss the difference between
a live connection and an extract
connection first it's important to note
that these different types of
connections are not available in tableau
public it's always a live connection and
a live connection is where the data will
update based on when the source of the
data updates so if any if you're
connected to a database and something in
the database changes then you'll pick up
those changes when you open the report
as it will query that database
when the report is opened whereas an
extract connection is extracted
into creates a subset of the data that
improves performance so when you're
looking at it locally on your computer
you have an extract of that data set
that subset of the data right on your
computer or up in tableau server
depending on where you're looking at it
and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when your refresh updates it so
without a refresh set for that extract
you won't get the new data as an example
of this let's say
that in our
sample superstore we have kelly williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
sarah smith
and
we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in over
here in our extract
it sarah smith doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet 1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day
or once every several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau so here we have the people table
but let's say we want to join it to our
orders information so i'm going to start
with our orders table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what
two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side
and the people side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join a right join and a full outer
join let's review quickly what these
look like so say we had two tables that
we wanted to join together one of them
was the student table that had the
student names and the key
to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade a b c d f and incomplete
we can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take
the rows where the join could complete
so
we have one that could join to one just
fine but we don't have two and we don't
have three a doesn't join to anything so
this row would be not included
and then four
five and six would all join so that
would look something like this where we
would see adam
um when we grab student from this table
and grade from this table we can see
adam had an a beverly had an a dale had
a d elizabeth had an f and frank is
incomplete and charles is missing also
you don't see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join
it's going to take everything from the
left table
and only the pieces from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar to our inner join
only charles shows up so the join wasn't
able to complete since a doesn't exist
in grade but we include charles anyways
and grade becomes null
for charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table
so we try to look up a inside of the
grade table we can't find it and never
tolerance no we look up a inside the
grade key perfect right join is like a
left join only it takes everything from
the right table instead of the left
table
so it grabs all the grades a b
c d f and incomplete and only the rows
from the left table that join
appropriately
so since charles isn't joined
appropriately he doesn't show up we also
have b and c showing up even though it
doesn't exist in the student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables
whether or not the join is complete so
we have all of the people where the join
completes we also have charles where the
join doesn't complete from the left to
the right and we have b and c where the
join doesn't complete from the right to
the left
so those are our options in tableau
here
in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is
not in
the people table that's when you would
do a left join
for our purposes
we'll do an inner join
now let's say
we had a second
excel sheet
here
that had more
orders and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders
by dragging that second orders table
right underneath the original orders
table you can see it says their drag
table to union and that's helpful for if
you have an excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders and then
add the rows instead of the columns for
the 2016 orders
for example we've added people
but as a join and that will
first put in all of our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order
columns so it would have the same data
the same order id ship date but we
wanted to add more rows then that would
be one new union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category
we also have
percentage of total sales a long table
down so the difference between these two
things are one of them is made using
a calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales which basically makes the database
find the total sum of sales regardless
of
these dimensions we pulled on
so it gives us our total number so this
will be sum of sales for bookcases and
this will be sum of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one
percentage of total sales along table
down is what's called a table
calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done in
tableau
it's processed locally right inside of
the table after the aggregations have
occurred
there are some pros and cons of doing it
this way so
for
this percent of total sales
i had to create the table calculation
here
and it does the fixed
sum of sales where it finds the sum of
sales for the entire database and since
it is fixed it will ignore filters so
for example
i took off both of the sales and i'm
just going to put on the percent sum of
sales
and let's say we wanted to see
how
office supplies and technology are as
percentages of sum of sales
and ignore furniture so we can grab
category and we'll control
click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit okay
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
whereas
if we take
sales
and double click it and adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation
and click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match and that's
because it does take into account the
filter of category so let's pull the
filter category off and we can see that
they're both out of 100 now and each of
these take into account
the same amount of data since we have no
filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table
then you need to use a table calculation
however when you push the information
back to the database to do the
calculation it's doing it as part of the
query to the data source and it can save
you some time and so which one of these
is faster sort of depends on
what data is available already when the
original query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
tableau
first let's add a second data source so
we can do that by coming up to data and
clicking new data source
or you can just click this plus data
source right here and click microsoft
excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store
pull on sales
and we will rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them
based on who had the highest sales to
the lowest sales
we could create a calculated field
called ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank
function
and we're going to put in sales now we
receive this error here so when we hover
we see what that arrow says oh you can
click and it says all fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated
so
we can make sum
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when i click on rank it
will tell us that it returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row
and it says identical values are
assigned an identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on rank by sales now
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one
d is next and c and b are tied
20 and 20.
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place
but now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these
we'll click duplicate
and edit
let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click ok double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five
it goes one two three four so it doesn't
include that gap now let's give them a
little bit more space here
and maybe i want it to be in the order i
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that will move sales to the front
and put rank dents at the bottom so now
we can see sales we can see rank by
sales we rank dents by sales
now let's duplicate
and
look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and change the name here you notice that
i receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on ring
modified and it says it returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place
they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same rank
here but they receive the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank unique
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two
three four and five
so what it's doing is
let's quickly look here so
rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it
ascending or descending that means that
do we want to rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you will
define so it defaults to descending and
it's saying the biggest is the best
so
in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do for
and it's doing that based on the ascii
values
of
the store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase b comes
before lowercase c uppercase b is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data
and we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before
in our tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask and the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at
category so we'll drag category onto
columns and then we're going to look at
sales so we'll drag sales onto rows and
it will create three bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
onto rows again
and let's
take
subcategory and bring it onto color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to
move from the sales by category sheet to
the sales by subcategory sheet and also
filter down that sheet to only the
category we want to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list
and what sheets do we want to affect
we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other
data source if we click rank example it
will show the rank example data source
so we just want sales by category to be
the source sheet
and the target sheet we want it to be
sales by subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available
to create this filter and hit ok so now
we have our go to subcategory on select
we'll hit ok again
and
let's
make this a little wider so we can see
and so when we click on furniture it
will take us to only furniture
of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make tableau drill to a lower
level
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions
you can see that we have the action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets
sales by category and sales by category
2. let's say we don't want that and we
can unselect sales by category 2
and hit ok
now when we go to worksheet actions
now you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory
great so we have our sales by category
two let's bring it to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories
in the colors there
now we can take a look
here
and sort by
subcategory based on some of sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just
a way that i like to view it so
let's do
a highlight action and we're going to do
it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory
and look at it over top of our sales by
category stacked over top of sales by
sap category so we want both of those
let's make our
dashboard automatic for
testing purposes
and we'll go to dashboard we'll click
create actions so we're going to add an
action it's going to be a highlight
action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet
and the sales by subcategory be the
target sheet for all fields okay
okay and on select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
i want to see all these small ones or i
want to see
this one and these small ones or
whatever then it will highlight the ones
that you drag and select now this is
also true of our sales by subcategory
and sales by category so when we clicked
on technology it filtered to just
technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click
office supplies and technology we get
office supplies and technology now if we
go back to the dashboard we can see that
this is now filtered also to office
supplies and technology and that's
because we're using the same sheet
and when you navigate away from that
sheet it doesn't mean that your filter
goes away
so when i clicked undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so
if you're going to have two
things affect that sheet
just remember that just because you
navigated away from what you selected
doesn't mean that what you selected
goes away that filter will stay there
and it shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a url action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so i'm going to double click state
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a field
map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put state onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label
so we can see the sales amount let's
quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
now we're gonna
lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on
great so now we have our sales map and
we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and the
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to url
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet
sheet 6 which we should rename and we're
going to have a url in here so this will
take us to wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
wikipedia so
we're going to take state and add it to
the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up
okay click ok let's rename our sheet to
url
filter by state and so when we click on
texas
okay back to url filter by state let's
go to our worksheets
and go to our actions and on the go to
sub category
it is also affecting this url filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here and sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it won't auto select no sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover around texas and wait long enough
oh yeah on click sometimes you just have
to hold still it'll come up with our
little link here and we click on wiki
and it will open up
our browser with the wikipedia page for
texas this can become really handy in
the event that you have data that maybe
has an order id and you can take that
order id and insert it into a url in
your system so that it can take you to
your web interface page for that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of california
which it can have information about the
languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to url action
on select
and since it's on select the name of
this url won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to me with something unique
let's put in our wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on oklahoma
it'll open up a page for oklahoma
but let's unselect oklahoma
if we drag on web page from the objects
here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit ok and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on oklahoma
instead of taking us to oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to texas and this will change to texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
lines
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics pane
and it is something that comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so
let's make
our visualization we'll do our category
and subcategory again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it onto text that's not
what i want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to analytics
and we go to drag our reference line
onto
our visualization it says you can add
the reference line for the whole table
for a pane or for a cell
so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to define our cell
so each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
so each one of them gets a reference
line you see how it added those on this
is our dialog box we will look at that
in just a moment
so let's remove that if we take
reference line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to have a
category on a color so each of these
different colors
is now a pane
reference line onto pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it onto table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do
find out the average for each
section so i'm going to take category
put it back onto color and we'll take
reference line and put it onto pain
now we have our reference line it's
based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it was taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs
so taking an average across these added
up sections we could also have it be
total
where it's adding all of these up and it
makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case a constant which is where you
get to define the value and so if we
wanted it to be 200
000 there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average
or the median so let's stick with
average and now you can see it's
labeling the line as average we could
also have it label the line as the value
so now we can see that the average is
this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon
and then the value average
this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
ok
and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our
recalculated average line
so the average for tables for just
tables
is the sum divided by the number so the
sum of tables is 206 966 divided by one
is still two or six nine sixty six so
selecting just tables isn't really
helpful but if we wanted to know the
average of
tables and we'll control click
appliances
and we'll control click binders oh there
we go all three of those are selected we
can see the average of those three which
is this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those
five categories
and those are reference lines
now let's duplicate this sheet
and i'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to
reference bands
click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pain or per cell so
let's do a reference band for the whole
table so it's doing entire table
and it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum
now we could change the minimum to be
the average to the maximum and now that
will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to
average to maximum and then you can
change things like you can add lines so
we have a line for the average of the
maximum you can make it thinner you can
make it dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray
and you can have show recalculated band
for highlighted or you can remove that
and that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making
several different kinds of
visualizations such as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learn team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to
look at it by state
and we're going to look at it by
ship mode
and so we'll take average stasis ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's
change the order of these really quick
if we come up here to ship mode and we
click sort and we click manual we can
have same day above first class so that
it kind of goes in order of priority so
same day first class second class
standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do
if
the
average days ship
is less than or equal to two
then
we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't uh
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're gonna call it an
early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
late
and
else if let's get the rest of them
average days to ship is
not less than two
greater than two
and less than
five
then
on time
two words
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if and
that means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement
if statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it onto color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment
as orange and shipment linked as red
we could double click on the color and
we can change shipment early to green
and now we can see
the best ones the on time ones and the
ones that stand out as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the district of columbia
has second class as a legit late
shipment
you can see that all of these
share
the same axis size so they all go from
zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to six
if we click edit axis
you can choose if you want that to be
the case so it's like right now all of
them use uniform access range for all
rows and columns and that's really nice
because it's easy to compare colorado to
colorado to colorado if you change it to
independent access for each rose you can
see now this one only goes from zero to
not even one whereas this one goes from
zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart
based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
looks like at the end and talk about how
it works
so after we build it we'll talk about
some of the benefits of having a
waterfall chart so what we're going to
do is build it over time for this
visualization we're just going to look
at the year of 2014
so i'm going to filter it to the order
dates for 2014
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month
so you can see that i chose the one that
has month and year
and then i chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from
profit
to
our running total of profit
so you can see that it takes january and
then it adds february to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to we only have our running total
where it will some january and february
for the february mark and then some
january february march for the march
mark
if i take profit
and put it here you can see january is
negative 3 000 and february is positive
2 000. but here it's the sum of those
which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a gaunt bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have we're going to
call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit
with the negative sign in front
oh it looks like i've done this before
so
now we have a new name because i added a
space at the end so hit apply
and let's delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit
and we're going to use that to determine
the size
of the gaunt bar
so
what it does
is it takes where the line was and adds
the size of it to be the size of profit
but because the line was at the top and
we didn't want to build the profit up we
had to change it to negative profit so
it would build it down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit
and then let's take profit and put it on
color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns it orange
and when profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up each month and you can
see how much each month contributed
our biggest contributors are november
and march november being a little bit
bigger
and you can see where we started at the
beginning of that month and where we
ended and that's how a waterfall chart
works so it lets you go through over
time and see exactly where our problems
were
and exactly which months helped the most
where we started and where we ended for
each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order id
and it's going to add all members but
then i'm going to change order id
from a dimension to
a measure and we have account distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see
one person has 17 orders and we have
one two
three four
five six seven people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers
had how many orders and what number of
orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so
in order to do this
we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us
the number of orders per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer
so let's call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are
two other level of detail calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in
some of our simply learn classes and if
you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them so we're
going to do it fixed
and you can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order id
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors and
we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so
let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see
one two three four five six seven eight
up to 17. so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers order 17 and we had them order
everything in between so if we'd never
had a customer that had nine orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer
id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure
and it's going to be
account distinct
and so now we can see
how many customers ordered
how many items
so we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per
customer
perfect
now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to
do an analysis about new customers
so we'll call this level of detail
new customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time
we're going to
use these
so that it makes an axis
instead of just
change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous and then we're going
to take our customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
[Music]
account distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day i think day is too low of a level
let's go at month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
we click on central we can see central
now this is including all customers
but say we only wanted to include a
customer when they're making their very
first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
to their first order date the min
order date
nope
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together so we're
going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of
trying to return something different
based on the visualization it will
always return the min for each customer
id
so if the order date on the
visualization is equal to this order
date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new else
existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that it's a
new customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date
apply
okay and now we can take our new field
which is new or existing drag it onto
filters and we only want new
we'll hit apply
and we can see that we have new
customers
but
less over time
so
so now we're going to change this
count distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how
our new customers are adding up so it's
taking the prior value and adding our
new customers and then at the end we get
our total customers for each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day
and you can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then here for
the region of east there kind of is a
level spot where we're not getting new
orders
and that seems to be the same for each
of them so for february of 2014 why were
we not getting any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red it
looks like the west region
leveled out as well but picked up sooner
and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view
new customers over time
and it's only possible because we were
able to do a level of detail calculation
here on new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build
a map based on country so i'm going to
double click on country and it's going
to map out all the countries and then on
our marks i'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is
how much it contributes to population by
percentage so let's add a table
calculation and we're going to have it
do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label
and
let's put it on top so country names on
top now it's getting a little bit of
crowded in here so
we're going to un click show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that
we want to see specifically so when we
can right click on china here hover on
mark label and click always show
and on india
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here and that's just a manual way to
choose which ones have indicators labels
and which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an area
that explains that
china and india
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the
visualization and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on
a windows machine you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis
and we're going to bring on population
total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high
in your axis is you can uncheck this box
that says include zero and it will
not always include zero in your axis but
this can be misleading so you can see
that it looks like population growth is
something really dramatic by increasing
that slope of the line
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated
well and you're not doing it to
mislead your users
you just need to keep in mind that this
includes zero can change what your graph
is saying so we're going to
not include the zero at this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're gonna click on forecast and drag
it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
and see forecast result is
actual and forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up
here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change it says automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and it
will go out into the future
out to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also
have your trend line show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
trend
excellent we're going to make one more
visualization for this
and it's going to be a pie chart so the
pie chart is also going to be based off
of population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
and click your pie chart
great so i'm going to make this
the entire view so we can see the pie
chart better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so i have changed my mind and
instead of country i'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total
and we could keep it that way or we
could
do what we did last time
and change it to percent of total
so that on hover we can see
the population
and
the percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to
show asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have all those things we
selected and we have other let's edit
our group right click edit group
we're going to
rename this group
asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group
the rest of the world
okay
so now we have our group we can drag it
onto label and we can see asia and rest
of the world and now see how it's
breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on
our
detail right here so we pull region off
now let's just split asia rest of the
world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
now we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
great so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and
we have a range which has a minimum size
and a maximum size
some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will fill the screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right
if you have automatic then it will fit
the screen that it's displayed on
however
the things that you've placed might get
squished too close together
and then the range gives you a minimum
size and a maximum size meaning if the
screen is too big
it still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens
you at least know that it will never
make it get smaller than this particular
size so there's some benefits to that as
well where you still have a little bit
of control of what it will look like in
the end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that where you hover
it fills up that space and that's where
it's going to show up you can also
adjust the lines in between different
visualizations for things that need more
space or less space
another important thing to recognize is
that when you click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard
then it will do a standard fit
versus if you have
entire view where it will
make it fit into inside the box over
here we could have fit width
or fit height on some of the
visualizations it doesn't make as much
of a difference however when you have a
visualization that maybe has a lot of
text in it and they need to be able to
scroll you'll want to have it fit width
but you don't want it to fit height
because then it will shove all of that
information
into the box and not allow you to scroll
up and down
so as you saw as we dragged these on it
took
these
legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
has a couple of things wrong with it we
might not want the title of this to be
region group
so we could come in and we could edit
the title and then
maybe just call it region
however i don't think we need this
legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again
is unnecessary potentially because we
have our two population numbers
showing up right as we hover
so we'll remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
one of the quickest things you can do to
add functionality to the dashboard is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now
that
uses filter button
actually creates an action here
filter one generated that it's made on
its own now you can see that when we
click on
china
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
china click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
twenty percent or the twenty percent
here and the seventeen
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows a hundred percent
because it's filtered everything else
out of the chart so it now makes up one
hundred percent of the circle so that
doesn't make a lot of sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions
modify your actions so that they only
affect the things that make sense so we
can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify
only the trend
so now when we click on
china we see china's trend over time and
it doesn't affect our pie because that
doesn't make sense for it to affect our
pie
we might want to select
on our pie
asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
asia and now it zooms into asia on our
map and shows us just the asia world
population trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use filter
then we click on
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pi updates a little bit although it
hasn't been anything dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way
to add filters to your visualization
another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our trend
we could take the year we're going to
control click and drag it onto filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time
or a range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit ok
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so we clicked remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years
so let's drag year onto the filters
we're just going to do the year number
next and here's all the years we're
going to let all of them be selected for
now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up and we can make it like
a drop down so they can still select
multiples but it's a drop down or maybe
we want this visualization to be just
one year at a time so we can choose
single value in a list and it lists out
all the years or in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012
and
then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year of year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so i tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what i publish
so we're going to single value drop down
we're going to
[Music]
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are
come here to layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container
we have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this view
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side
and a vertical container allows things
to be a one on top of the other and so
in our vertical container we see all
this extra space for extra things to be
on top of each other but if we wanted to
have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was
even though all the other things shifted
so that's one of the disadvantages of
floating is that you're kind of just
manually choosing
where it will stand
using your x and y position
and it's not dynamic
so let's give us a little bit less space
up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container
and we will say
population dashboard
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you can give it more or less space
let's bring
our legends down to places where they
make sense again
perfect
and so now
we have this
that will affect this
only
and show you just 2012
2011 2010 so we don't want it to affect
the trend because we want the trend to
show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync
and so the dashboard is basically for
2012 except for the trend which shows
you the past in the future so one way
that you can do that is clicking apply
to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization
or in this dashboard
and you can click show all worksheets in
workbook and then if there were other
worksheets that we showed them so we
wanted to do asia versus rest of the
world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to
click on a country and have it
make the change if we instead want to
have a filter for country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters we'll have it show all for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and add
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filters so that's
a nice
feature of tableau where it can kind of
guess where you might want things we're
going to do multiple value drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing i like to do
on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see i've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
i wanted to look at turkey so i found
turkey and then i hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect
so now we have a dashboard complete with
filters and actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user i
press escape and get back out
and it doesn't give you these highlights
when you hover over things that are
dashboard formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way
and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around health information
so first we're going to make
a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it
birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate on to
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is
more associated with countries that have
poor health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our
higher birth rate countries highlighted
in red next we're going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized as having
an alarming birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to
do a rank
on that
do you see sometimes
when you're auto-completing your
statements
it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if i type if or i start to type if and
then i come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because i was typing it
right next to it so if i put a space and
then i start to type if and i click if
it will not delete rank so we're going
to say if
the rank of average is
less than or equal to
50 so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we could take this again
is greater than 50
then
normal over 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases so with these if statements just
make sure that you're always getting all
the different options
that you want but in this case
we defined both however we didn't have
to define the second calculation because
if it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom the rest
so we're going to hit ok
and then we're going to put birth rate
class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and i am seeing alarming birth rate on
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit ok
and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place i would look if it's
not doing what you would expect so
we'll put it back to automatic okay
the second place i would look is inside
of the table calculation that is created
so when we defined rank here
we put a table calculation on it so when
we right click here we get edit table
calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close
this and
we are done here one thing you could do
is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure
that every label shows up but it gets
super crazy in there so there are some
times where the labels may overlap a
little bit and so you'll want to select
this option in our case we don't want
that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map based on rank our next
visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do
a chart across time so we're going to
click year and bring it on to columns
and we're going to change it to
this
year
in the continuous section so now we have
an axis
and
we're going to
double click on female life expectancy
up
there we go double click on female like
expectancy and then double click on male
life expectancy so what that did was
made us two charts
one on top of the other but we don't
want that so we'll take this off and
we're going to drag male life expectancy
right onto this axis for the female life
expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended axis chart so they necessarily
use the same axis and they necessarily
have the same kinds of marks so we'll
take a look and see what the difference
is there so if i were to change this to
a bar chart we would have
bar chart for both of them and i can't
define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart now if we
go back to
when we just had female life expectancy
and we drag
male on next to it and we have two
charts
now we can change it to a dual axis and
we have one on top of the other however
our axes don't line up we can see at the
top here is 15k and over here it's 14k
so we're going to synchronize the axis
and you can see
one on top of the other
and
we have two marks cards so we could have
this one be a bar chart and that would
be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
access chart so i'm going to take mail
and drag it here
and we have our blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here
is really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by
right-clicking on the measure down in
this measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since i only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's
drag on forecast
so it's forecasted out the next two
years for both line
and we'll bring on trend
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see
each individual point for the life
expectancy for females and males and we
can see what they're expected to be in
the future
and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different
measures so we'll just call it a heat
map for now
and for our heat map we're going to look
at the different countries so we'll
bring country onto rows and we're going
to look at
their
birth rate
so i just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on
we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
gdp so how much they spend on
gdp
so when i double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measure names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values
define
what's in the text right here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate
and
the life expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate
we definitely want to have
decimals afterwards
as a matter of fact the birth rate is a
percentage so instead of doing a number
standard we'll just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate
and for
percent of gdp for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these
we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the
for all of these we could change it from
a sum to an average in the default
properties
under aggregation
so it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
i won't do that at this time because i
get a little bit confused sometimes when
i don't have my sum on there by default
because that's what i'm so used to
seeing by default great so we now have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it on to color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square
and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors darkly
the higher the number it is in this case
and
right now it's doing it for the whole
area so one percent is obviously much
much smaller than 82 but if we wanted to
be able to look at birth rate
independently from life expectancy we
can right click on the measure values on
the color and click use separate legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends
and we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color to another
color we used the
red gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use
another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from
light to dark and then you can choose
what color you want as your dark color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending on health
and that is our heat map
with
separate legends
so let's build this all into a dashboard
now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates
then we're going to bring on our
heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our legends here
and we're going to move our legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put
our legends
into the horizontal container
and um let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh
so birth rate is going to be over here
great now
one thing we can do is make these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so it would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width so once you start to
drag the size on something it no longer
is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one's not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be
even bigger
then it will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be
now let's take a look at filters oh
before we take a look at filters i want
to look at this map one more time
because i think that it would be useful
for our colors to be
a little bit more
distinct
so
one quick way to navigate to your
worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button
and while we're here i'm going to click
on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from this
sequence to a stepped color
and we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be
this color this color this color and
when i hit ok
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic
in our differences and it's put
everything into the three categories we
defined so let's go back to our
dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard which ones aren't
and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're going to hit ok
and we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
[Music]
allow them to
choose years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year
because we want to be able to see it
over time and if we filter down the time
then we don't get as much context so
we'll hit ok
let's go back to our dashboard
if i click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat
map because i told it to apply to that
one as well so here's the country oh
i made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and apply to worksheets selected
worksheets
see i wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
i clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now
we get the year of year as well so we'll
click year of year let's put it over
here
and we're going to make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it
even smaller
great and let's change our country
to be
a single value drop down so you can pick
one at a time and let's also change it
or this year of year since we can select
multiples let's change it so that
on customize that you show the apply
button
so here since they can only select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since they can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years and then hit apply and then
you'll see the changes
and you can see that even though i've
selected only 2011 and 2012 you still
see all the years on this line chart as
expected
and there
is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy
our first sheet is going to be another
map that is going to have to do with
overall gdp
and
as we usually begin with maps by double
clicking on country
and changing it to a map mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
gdp onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do
a custom diverging so you get to pick
both colors
and let's pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay red for there and then we want to
do maybe like a deeper
green
and that way
you can see who has the highest gdp
which is green
we hit apply
okay
and then it will
eventually get lighter and lighter until
it goes to gray which then will lead to
green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call
gdp versus gdp per capita
so
gdp or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis and then another
measure which is going to be
gdp per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with gdp and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that
and we're going to call it
gdp
per capita
and we're going to take
some
of gdp
and divided by the sum
of the total
population
population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis
there we go
and then we have gdp per capita so
what this will do is sum up the gdp
across whatever measures we have in
place go across whatever dimensions we
have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row
and then
doing an aggregation on it
okay
so now we're going to bring on gdp per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of gdp and the gdp
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high gdp per capita
and some countries have a high gdp
overall but not as high of a gdp per
capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic
to
circles and now they're dots like you
might see on scatter plot
and you can
drag region
onto
color
and now we can see our different regions
and see we see a lot of reds here
and
um it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing
how much countries spend on health care
as a part of their gdp so we're going to
rename it
to be gdp on
healthcare we're going to look at each
of our countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense gdp
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show
the health expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on gdp
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their gdp on health
we can again bring region under color
so we can see the different
regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this
and drag it onto the labels and we can
see that it's a percentage but it's
coming up as a number so
we can right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control
and drag that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure
necessarily what currency this data set
is in
it's worth checking out
what currency it is in
so for now we'll just have it as a
number
and now we're going to
customize our tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tool tip and we want
it to tell us the country in the top so
erase region
and we're going to
erase country label and center country
and then we're going to
put
this
country spends
this percentage
on healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example marshall island
spends 2.1 on healthcare we'll hit enter
and then when we hover
it tells you the country and it has our
custom tooltip on both visualizations or
on both of the different axes
so
let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
healthcare
visualization
and our gdp versus gdp per capita
and we'll move our legends to the top
again
by adding a horizontal container to the
top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these legends are just side by side
just above the map and the jdp per
capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
tableau is you can see this outlier of
the united states is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any trends there
so you could right click on it and click
exclude
and then it will exclude it from your
data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all
okay
and we're going to apply it to
worksheets so i showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see the
countries on the filters for this
visualization but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see country because it's in the
details of the information so
either way when we add country
since i added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we wanted to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a url action add action go to url
and when we click on a country on the
overall gdp map we want it to take us to
the wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country
so that is
this url and it's going to say
wikipedia for economy of
and we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit okay
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it and we can
click on
canada
and it will take us to the wikipedia
page for the economy of canada
great we click on brazil
same thing
so if we unselect on brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations
and so we could click use this filter
here and then when we click on france
it will filter these two other
visualizations to france
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
germany
germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click france and
germany and switzerland
and austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest gdp is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data
for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization
when you publish it to server or you can
deal with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so
let's make a bar chart that includes
every country and then we're going to
bring on days to start a
business and we will sort it smallest to
biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to
filter it to only those that have a good
market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to define business friendly
market
well
we're going to define our market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market
and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
elsif
space to start a business
is
greater than
then
business
might or might not
work
doing by less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to define these two
different markets so we'll hit
apply there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good market
and we're going to look at
just one year
look at 2012.
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region
and we can see
which regions tend to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to
move on and build our next visualization
which is also a bar chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we can bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it
a measure so the ease of business is at
this point looking at it like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum
but if we here convert it to a measure
then it also automatically made it a
count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do
like the sum of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the
average of ease of business
and then we want to have the smallest on
the top we do have some that don't have
ease of business ratings so we're going
to filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select ease of business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and
we're going to
segment this by creating another header
we're going to call that
business
friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is
so i guess this is a nice thing to know
so if if we start typing in what we want
to see then we can select it from a list
here but you can also interact outside
of this box so you could just grab ease
of business and drag it into the dialog
box here and that's really nice so we're
going to say if it is greater than or
equal to one
and less than or equal to
three
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement won't work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an end
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this
if statement goes through
one condition at a time so it's already
classified everything that's between
these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business
is
less than or equal to 10
then
we'll call it very
very business friendly regulations
we'll keep going
else if ease of business is
less than or equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150
then
strict
so
the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because
these sections 1 to 3 and then 3 or well
4 to 10
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred
for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply and we'll
bring business friendly onto our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so
we want to define what order these go in
so we're going to click sort
and we want the
most business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay
so we have our top three that are the
most business friendly and then we've
got four through ten which are very then
we've got our moderate
are strict
and are
not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there
and now we're going to make this even
more useful by adding the business tax
rate onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly
is like singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27
whereas if you get down to
some of these
that are not preferred
some of them have really low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like saudi arabia
and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that second decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be
a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay
now let's make
some annotations so we could come and
click here on this mark
and then we can annotate that mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here
and so we could
use some of this information
so i'm going to copy that
and i'll put some hard returns there
so we're going to say
that this country
is the most
business friendly
but has a
business tax rate
of and let's grab the tax rate
and then we'll erase this
and we'll hit okay
and i've made a typo so singapore is the
most business friend is not what i meant
to say
so i can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around
draws the line to singapore which is the
mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation
for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
high
business taxes
i could change that size make everything
fit
now we have this
second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our axis
and we're going to
look at mobile phone usage so i double
clicked it shows mobile phone usage over
time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries and then we're going to bring
on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to
also make that average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently
and so we can make it a dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their rates however
the uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and then move that on to the front okay
and now it's made each of these wide and
there's like a star point and end point
on the axis for the bar and that comes
here under size
where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can define the size of the bars so we're
going to make those bars like this
now we can see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to
orange
since red might apply that it's bad
in some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending and so this will all come
together on our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that i have a sheet called
as a business and a dashboard that i've
called ease of business but it won't let
you create a dashboard with the same
name
as your worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and
we're going to bring on our
days to start business
visual our ease of business visual
and our
phone and internet visual
let's
put our legends at the top again
so we'll make
our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
so let's see why that's happening if we
go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show filter
and if we change the filter
to 2011. okay it's not showing up here
and the only filter i can see that could
be removing it is this averages of
business
that is removing anything that is null
so if i pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years i select i'm not
seeing any
ease of business information
so
we're going to want to set this
to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so
let's go back until we're back to the
state
we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
that only selects 2012
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change your view it only
changes this visualization
sometimes that's useful to note
sometimes it's useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this
right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like
here
that makes it clear that
it's just changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter
and that way we can click on new zealand
and we can see it's the most business
friendly regulations and we can see its
internet and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper
change so some of them have
adopted phone and internet usage and
have stayed pretty similar whereas other
ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet i click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop-out arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
and we can bring country on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at afghanistan
okay
we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review
we have made
a dashboard on population
we made one about health
we made one that had to do with our
economy
and one that had to do with our ease of
doing business
here's a story about these two gentlemen
talking about tableau the first
gentleman comments on how the ipl
cricket league was very entertaining
this year and how he believes that de
villiers scored the maximum runs but the
second gentleman says he has stats which
shows that khali outperformed this time
how did you come up with these stats
there's a tool that helps visualize data
by creating interactive charts and
graphs it's basically a business
intelligence tool used by many
organizations for visual data analysis
tableau helps us gain insights by
visualizing the data that you already
have so tableau is important when it
comes to visualization it has many
advantages first it has speed of
analysis so you can get into your data
and start analyzing it very quickly
second it helps users be self-reliant
and not rely on very difficult analytics
tools to start digging into their data
third it allows you to do visual
discovery so as you're building you can
learn information and insights about
your data four you can use it to blend
diverse data sets and five you can use
the data sets that are centralized so
after you've put together a data set you
can publish it out and more people can
use it than just you that sounds
interesting how about we visually show
the stats of ipl so first we'll look at
connecting to data this will be the
first step in tableau
so if you have opened up your workbook
and you see this page you can click here
connect to data
and we're going to choose a text file
and we're going to join our deliveries
data
to
our matches data so we click deliveries
at broaden deliveries and we can click
add
and bring in another text file called
matches
next we'll talk about joins we will make
use of joins when we have multiple data
sets to work with suppose we want to
join these two data sets one of which
has a team id and what city that team is
in the other one has a team id and tells
you the name of the team there are four
ways to join data sets an inner join the
resulting table contains values that
have matches in both tables so we can
see here that we have delhi and the deli
daredevils we also have chennai and
tonight super kings we have bangalore
and then we have this team that doesn't
exist in bangalore and so since these
two don't match since we have two two
three three but then we have four and
six these two don't exist in our
resulting table because they don't have
matches in both tables in a left join
resulting table contains all values from
the left table and the corresponding
matches from the right table so we have
delhi tonight and bangalore and then we
have their matches however bangalore
does not have a match so it is left null
in a right join we have the opposite the
resulting table contains all matches
from the right table and the
corresponding matches from the left
table so we have the daredevils the
super king and then we have king
punjab and they all exist however number
six does not have a corresponding city
and so that's left null and in a full
outer join the resulting table contains
all values from both tables so we still
have delhi and chennai and we have
bangalore and we have the kings but
their nulls their corresponding nulls
exist as well so since this one doesn't
have a match it still shows up but you
get a null and then this one doesn't
have a match it also still shows up and
you get a null
now it's going to
allow us to join our two
different data files and together
so we have to decide which field to join
on in this case it is match id
and then on the matches it's just called
id
and that is id
we'll do an inner join that will select
only the records that match between the
two fields
so it's given us some
sample data underneath from our two
things and we look at match id here and
where it's one
here
we'll scroll over and see that it's one
for id
if we scroll down and find a different
number so here we have two
for id and we scroll over and match id
is now two
and we have our join in place
dimensions and measures dimensions are
qualitative fields that cannot be
aggregated for example batsman and
batting team etc however measures are
numerical values that mathematical
functions can work on like batsman runs
and extras so for the case of batsman
runs you can sum up all of the runs for
an entire game or that took place in a
city or for an individual batsman and
that's how you can tell that it works
with a mathematical function now we'll
move on to the last part of dashboard
designing so we can move on to
sheet1
it will take a second and load our query
and now we have
the
worksheet space and this is where we can
build our visualization
this is called a worksheet you can also
build a dashboard
which is where you can put multiple
worksheets together
and you can build what's called a story
which is where you can take worksheets
and dashboards and put them in
an order to tell a story
so on our worksheet
we'll have this space here in the middle
which is where you can build the
visualization
you have
columns and rows
where you can drag on your data which is
here on the left here's our data
dimensions on top measures on bottom
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second
we have columns and rows
where you can drag your information and
it defines where the columns
go or where the data goes to define the
columns where the data goes to define
the rows
we have places here these are our cards
and when you drag things onto these
different cards it will do different
things to your visualization
and
let's talk about our dimensions and
measures so tableau will take its best
guess
at what your data is so it's guessed
that all of these blue fields on the top
are dimensions
and dimensions are
qualitative data so
data that defines
and like describes
the rest of your data and so
usually it can be things like city so
you can say here's a city and then we
can look at our
different
measures by the city that it took place
in for example with financial data you
could pull on city and you could look at
sales by city and city is the dimension
which is a quality and then sales would
be a measure which is something that is
quantitative
and it is able to be aggregated
whereas dimensions are not things you
would like to aggregate so some things
can be
a number
but they're still not a measure such as
a phone number
nobody is going to
want to sum up different people's phone
numbers and see what the sum of the
phone number is however you might want
to look at a customer and see their
phone number
and puts it up in the dimension area
another thing that tableau does in this
case
by default it will make little folders
for your different data sources so we
have our deliveries data source
and our matches data source
we go back to our data source section
that corresponds
to our two different files
you can also look at these sample fields
here and the part where it's blue at the
top represents the blue table
and if we keep dragging we'll see
the orange coming in which represents
the orange table
so here we are back at sheet 1
and let's start building our first
visualization
i'm going to right click here click
rename and we're going to call it
matches in each
venue
so we're going to start off by making a
map
tableau has recognized the word city
here and put this little globe next to
it meaning that it has recognized it as
having the geographic role of city
so if i double click on it
it maps out some cities
now it's having a hard time
mapping the cities so we're going to
click edit location
and it
doesn't recognize these places or it
could exist in multiple places because
it's defaulted the country to the united
states
so if we change that defaulted country
to india
then
we have much fewer unknown
fields
so we're going to focus on india
and
not
look at these other
locations because some of these are not
in india and but we're going to make
this visualization for india
specifically if you wanted to show
what countries they were in you can
define
from what field you can find the country
information so if we had two
fields in here one was city and one was
country that told you what country it
was then you would choose this from
field and you'd choose that country
dimension
and that would fix our problem assuming
things were spelled right and put in the
right countries in this case we don't
have country so we have defined india
and that's what we're going to focus
next
we're going to bring city
onto color as well and now they each
have their own colors and here's our
legend
and we want these to have a different
size based on how many matches they've
had
so we're going to bring on id
size
and
we
wanted to actually count
those ids so we changed it to account
distinct and now you can see the
littlest ones have around two and as
they get bigger this
to this size is 20 and the size is 85
and when you hover you can see exactly
how many they have
you can adjust the size using this size
marks card
make our circles a little bit bigger
we can adjust our color
by adding a border
maybe like a black border
but then changing the opacity
so we can see through it a little bit
for those that go over borders
and start to overlap
and if we wanted to see the exact number
without having to hover we could take
this id onto
label
and again
change it to account distinct
there we go
and now you can see exactly how many
there are in each location
you can change where the labels show up
by adjusting the alignment so we could
have it in the center and it kind of
shows up inside their circles but that's
kind of hard to read in these smaller
circles so we could define that we
always want it at the top
or something like that
we could also have it say the city name
so if i drag city on the label
now it shows 9 and then the city but if
i want to change the order of that
see how it does the count and then the
city
i could drag
so you saw right inside of here we have
two that are on labels so they have this
little t inside of a box and now city is
on top
of count
of id so city and then count
we could also allow
people to filter
so if we click show filter here
and if we just want to look it'll zoom
in on the countries you select so if we
just wanted to look at a couple of them
then we could select individual ones
or if we wanted to exclude certain ones
then we can make it easy to exclude
great so now we have our visualization
for matches in each venue
next we're going to make another
worksheet by clicking down here and
we're going to name this one
top run scorers
and this will allow us to be able to
find who scores the top runs and so
we're going to
make
a visualization
called a tree map
using this show me button we haven't
explored show me yet show me will show
you what visualizations you can build
based on what you've selected
over here so when we selected city it
shows us that we can make maps using
city what we're going to do
is look at
city
and
i'm going to hold control
and click batsman and i'm going to hold
ctrl and click batsman run
and now you can see that tree map is
highlight as filled in not grayed out
anymore so we can select that
and it is showing us
what batsmen
have the most runs
we want the color to be based on city so
let's drag city onto color
and now we can see that it's separated
out by city
and you can see the person
at the very top right with the biggest
square has the most runs
but then you also get a second benefit
of being able to know which city seems
to have the most runs associated with it
so it looks like mumbai
has the most
runs let's also
filter this information so let's bring
on
batsman runs and we can choose sum
and let's filter out batsmen who didn't
get
a total of
400 runs
there we go so now we only see batsmen
and cities that have a sum bigger than
400 runs
okay so we have city on label
but maybe we just want to be able to see
that on hover so we'll take city off of
label and now we just see
the batsmen who have the highest runs
for each city
and
we'll also bring on
the number of runs
onto the label
so now we can see the batsman in their
runs and exactly how many
runs they have
you can always get to how many they have
based on hover
we'll go on to our next visualization
and that's going to be
win percent
based on
toss
decision
so we're going to see
which
decision you make based on the toss
leads to a win more often so you can
choose to bat or you can choose to field
and if you choose to bad do you win more
than if you choose to field so let's
take a look
we have our toss decision
and we also have
if they won the match or not match
winner
and i'm going to control click toss
decision
and we're going to select pi
so here we have a pie chart that colors
it based on toss decision which is bat
and field
and makes the angle and the size of the
circle based on the match winners now
we're only going to have the
angle be based on match winner or not
and then we can define the size ourself
so we can make it bigger
i'm going to change this visualization
to fit the entire view so that we can
see the pi better
great but we don't see a percentage so
let's change this sum
of match winners to a table calculation
so we're going to click add table
calculation
and we're going to change it to percent
of total
we'll close that so now when we hover it
says 60 of the time matches were won
by the people who chose filled
and 39 were won by the people who chose
bat
let's make this into a label as well so
i'm going to control drag toss decision
onto label
and what that does is make a copy and
add it to label instead of pulling it
off of color so let's see what happens
if i don't hold ctrl so if i just drag
toss decision on the label it got rid of
it off of color and just put it on the
label and that's confusing there's two
pieces but they don't look any different
so ctrl drag fixes that we'll do the
same thing
for
that
match
percent of total that we made match win
percent of total
one of the benefits of having these
labels here
is that it allows you to be able to use
this visualization
even if you take a screenshot and send
it to somebody
and they can't hover over the top and
see what everything means another thing
you can do
is annotate it
and so
we can click annotate the point or the
mark
and it will give you this box and then
it will put in
some information that's showing up in
your tool tip and you can modify this
and
we can change this so it's not bold
anymore or leave it both and when you
hit okay
it is
makes this box that you can move
tells you information about that point
or that mark
you do the same thing here
and draws a line
and this allows you to
put notes about it you can see that
these parts
are dynamic so it just fills in toss
decision based on your field from over
here and it will change if it changes so
will the percent match winner
so for example this is for
everybody over all time but if we show a
filter
for city it adds it to our filters card
up here and then we could filter it to
just
this city
and you can see that they have updated
and
in this city
they have more people who have chosen
to bat win the game and so you don't end
up with
old static information
in either place
but if you did want to make a note
manually about
what you think is happening here
then you can do that as well
we could also do the same thing with
date
and now you could choose just what year
you want to see so just 2017
and in 2017 the field advantage was a
lot higher
and here's 2016.
and that's all time our next
visualization is going to explore the
idea of
if you win the toss how likely you are
to win the game
so we're going to look at historical
data and see what's happened in the past
so we're going to call this
advantage
of toss winning
so we're going to bring on
all of the toss winning
teams
and we're going to
also bring on all of the
teams that actually want so
how it works
is we can see
all the teams and then you can see if
they won or not so we're going to
quickly make a couple of changes to this
the first one is
this team
changed its name
to this team name so we're going to
group those two teams into the same
group so that they are treated
like just one
and we're going to create a group based
off of winner
and we're going to grab the two team
names by control clicking
and click group
and it puts them together
let's replace winner with our winner
group
there you go so now you can see
those two teams are together
do the same thing with toss winner
create
group
one disadvantage to creating a group
is that it's very manual
and so
you have to manually create the group
and you have to manually update it so if
they change their name again you have to
change it again
and
it's nice to have the functionality and
tableau to make those changes in case
you don't have the functionality to make
the changes to the data source itself
but do keep in mind if you have to
manually group things together you have
to manually keep it updated as well
next we're going to exclude some data
so
we have this null here that we'll just
click exclude on
because that would be perhaps when a
winner was not declared
and we're going to remove some of these
teams that have holes in their analysis
and that could happen because they
didn't play all of the teams
or
so there was never a match with that
team
and so
here for example
they
played and they could have won
or this team could have won this team
could have won or this team could have
won
but these other teams don't seem to have
any matches against them so we can
come across here for the winners and
i'll control click
the teams
that we're excluding and then we'll just
come over here to exclude and you can
exclude a bunch at a time it just adds
it to the filters right here so if i
right click on edit filter you can see
all the teams we've excluded
and then we'll do the same thing on the
toss winners
and we'll control click
and exclude
and now we are left with all the teams
that seem to have available data
between them
and now we want to see
of these toss winners
who won the game so we're going to count
all of the matches
and that will
give us the information we need so i'm
going to grab id and put it onto text
now what it's doing is giving me all the
ids so i've got to right click on it and
change it to a measure
and change it to count distinct
and now it will show you
how many matches fit these categories so
for this team if they won
when this team wins the toss
then this team usually wins
which is the same team so i'm going to
widen this out so we can see
the names
better
so when the super kings win the toss the
super kings
won the game 42 times let's right click
here and we're going to
change it to
a table calculation again
four percent of total
and what that is saying
is that of all the games
where the super kings won the toss
they also won the game 64 percent of the
time
now you can read this with the numbers
fairly easily but it'll be a lot easier
if we can also show in color so i'm
going to change the marks to
square
and i'm going to ctrl drag this onto
color
and now we have what's called a heat map
and the color is stronger where the
percentage is higher you can see our
range over here
so you can see there's a pretty clear
advantage to the person who wins the
toss
they tend to be the one that wins the
game
when the daredevils win the toss the
person who wins the game the most
is the daredevils
let's take this visualization and use it
to analyze a different feature of the
game so i'm going to right click on the
worksheet and i'm going to click
duplicate so now we have the same
visualization twice
and i will rename it to be
called batting
first advantage
so here instead of toss winner we're
going to bring on batting team
but let's first create a group again so
we're going to
don't be confused by group by that's not
the same thing we'll go to create and
click group
we're going to put together
control click the team names that have
merged okay
and
let's drag
you see how it's not up here right next
to batting team that's because
they put the calculated fields that
we've been making outside of the folders
so
if you're looking for a calculated field
you can scroll down to the very bottom
and let's drag batting group right over
top of toss winner and it will replace
it right out of there
and we have our gaps again
because the toss winners that we
excluded only applied to that toss
winner so i can pull off this toss
winner filter we don't need it anymore
and then we will
control click
on the ones with the gaps
that we wanted to remove
click exclude okay
and now we have an analysis showing
how the batting team does
in our next visualization we're going to
explore who the leading
batsman is
and this could allow you to find out
who's the best if you were in charge of
putting together your team
so
we can
take all of the batsmen and put it on
row so now we have a list of every
batsman and we can bring batsman runs
onto columns and it will sum up all of
their runs
now what we can do is sort it
from biggest to smallest and we can see
who are our top batsmen
we can bring batsmen on to color so i'm
control dragging again
and then they each get their own color
one nice thing that you could do here is
show it filter it by the team
so here we have like team one and team
two but what we would be doing it is
filtering on batting team
so we're going to click show filter
and so if you wanted to see
well like this is the best overall but
let's see who was the best to ever work
for this team
and then it will sort it from best
down
and you can switch the team and if we
choose this one we should choose this
one as well
and then we can see who's the best
another thing that could be really
useful is seeing who's the best by year
so we can come here to date and click
show filter and now we can see this is
the best overall of these years but if
we just want to see most recently who's
the best that's a very different story
so filters can be very handy
for looking at a bar chart here
and getting the exact information you
want
we could also maybe just look at the top
five batsmen so what we'll do is we'll
drag batsman onto filters
and we'll create a conditional
filter based on top here
by field so we'll say top ten
we wanted to look at the top five so
we'll change that to five
and we're looking at the top five
batsmen based on the sum of their runs
so you could choose something else to
filter it by but we wanted to be based
on their runs and we hit apply
and there we go we just see the top five
and again if you just want to see the
top five for 2017 here's the top five
for 2017.
maybe 2016 and 2017 together
those are your top five
now if we wanted to be able to change
how many we see
and as the developer we could go in
and change it here
but if we wanted our end user to be able
to change it then they can't because
when this is published
you can't change your filters
that you can't change the filters that
are
the top conditional filters we can
change these filters that we show on the
report called quick filters
but not this guy
you can see we can see now that it's
choosing top five
but we we
can't select it
how many so let's get rid of that card
and let's make a parameter that will
allow them to select it so create a
parameter
and we're going to call this top
n
we're going to make it an integer
and it's going to be a range
we'll let them choose
between five and
thirty
and they can go up and down by five
we'll click okay so now we have here at
the very bottom parameters
and we can right click on it and click
show parameter control and now we have
this parameter over here called top n
it's sort of set to 5 and then if i
change it to 10
nothing's happening
that's because we made the parameter but
we haven't put it anywhere in this sheet
so we're going to put it right inside of
this filter
so you come here and we want to choose
top how many
you can do it based on a parameter and
we'll do it based on our top end
parameter okay
so now when we change it from 5
to 10
the parameter updates the filter
so
in presentation mode the user can come
in and choose how many they want to see
now we've only let them go up 30
but
that's to your discretion you could
have this parameter
do whatever you need
so we could say they can go up to a
hundred
and that changes our parameter now we
have all these little marks in between
and here i chose 80.
or you could even make it
so that they don't have a step size
they just have a range and then they
have just this little slider and it
could be any number in between
but not lower than five and not bigger
than a hundred
let's remove this filter
and we will also hide this card because
we won't give them the option to choose
how many they want to see in this case
we'll just show them all
so
for this next visualization we're going
to look at our top five
and we're going to see how they do over
time so again we're going to start on by
bringing on our batsmen
but we only want to see our top five so
let's bring batsman on the filters and
we'll do what i just showed with top
five
now since we don't have anything else on
this visualization it's not sure how to
define the top five
so we're going to do it with batsman
runs and we're gonna have the sum of the
batsman runs so top five players over
all time that have
the highest sum of best been runs
highest sum of runs so here we have them
and we're going to bring on their runs
and we'll sort them biggest to smallest
and next we're going to bring on a time
element so we can see it over time so
i'm going to drag date over here
and now it's doing a line chart for
every
with a dot for every year
and i'm going to change year from the
discrete year to the continuous year
so that it's an axis down here and now
we can see that i'm over time we can
bring batsmen onto color so we can see
the different color for each batsman
and here's how they're trending
and then we'll also bring
the batsman runs onto label
and now you can see how many runs they
had
next we're going to take a look at
finding out who our leading bowlers are
so let's bring all of our bowlers onto a
visualization
one way to look at this would maybe be
to see which bowlers have the least runs
associated with them
so we can bring the runs up here and
then sort it smallest to biggest
however they could have very few runs
associated with them because they don't
bowl very often so let's bring on match
id and change it to be
a measure that is a count
of match ids
and we can see
that the ones a lot of these with the
least amount of runs also have the least
amount of matches
so that's not a very good indicator
we have here what's called a dismissal
kind
and you can see
the reasons that
the batsman was dismissed
and one of them
is hit wicket so you can see any of the
bowlers that hit the wicket
so let's bring dismissal kind on to
filters and we'll just look at those
that hit the wicket
so we have these ones
that have hit the wicket and let's see
how many times they did that so we'll
actually bring on
down here number of records
and we'll sort it biggest the smallest
so now we can see that this bowler
has hit it twice in our limited set of
data
if we include all of the dismissal kinds
except for null so this means that they
were
dismissed for any of these reasons
we can see
which bowlers had the most dismissals
and let's bring bowler onto color
great then we'll rename it
deleting bowler
and we're going to do a similar thing as
we did with top five batsmen with
bowlers so
we could start with this visualization
and replace
by clicking right clicking and click
duplicate
let's bring it to the end
and now
instead of
top five
batsmen
we can change it to bowlers
but first let's bring in our dismissal
kind and only choose the ones
so here we can click exclude and we're
going to exclude null
and hit apply so we don't have the nulls
anymore we just have the ones that were
dismissed
and we're going to bring in the bowler
on top of the filters and we're going to
have it be based on
the top
count of dismissal kind
top five
okay and
we'll put bowler over top of batsman
and we'll take out the sum of batsman
runs
and put on
our number of records
and batsman didn't get removed when i
pulled bowler on top of it so i must
have accidentally pulled it in front of
it there we go batsman's gone
now here's a disadvantage to making a
copy and then changing it because it's
like what's happening here but it's
because batsman is still on color and
some of batsman is still on runs
so let's take number of records and put
it on to
runs onto the text
and then let's take bowler and put it
onto color
that clears things up quite a bit
so now we can see the bowlers over time
if we take year of date off
we can see which ones are the best
overall and we'll sort it
there we go and then we'll put year back
on
by dragging date up here
right clicking and changing it to a
continuous there we go so now we have
our top five
and we need to rename this
to top five bowlers
okay
so now we have all these visualizations
and we can start putting them together
into dashboards
so let's make our first dashboard
we're going to have the size
be automatic so it fills the screen here
you have some options with the different
sizes you can have it be a fixed size or
you can define the width and the height
you could also define the width and
height based on some of these presets
like a desktop browser or a laptop
browser
you could have that be automatic so it
fills the space
now this will have it fill the space on
any screen so if they're looking at a
much smaller resolution then it'll try
to squish all of your visualizations
into one size so i don't recommend
automatic for
a lot of visualizations because you need
to have extra space
and or if you define this should be here
and this should be over here then it'll
all squish it all together
there's also range where it's sort of
like it's automatic and it will adjust
based on what screen you're looking at
it however there is a minimum size and
it will never be smaller than that and a
maximum size and it'll never be bigger
than that
so it won't stretch or shrink your stuff
too far
before adding scroll bars
so here we have automatic
and
our first dashboard so
we're going to rename our dashboard
we're going to call it
overall
performance
oh the first one we're going to make is
going to be
looking at venue
and
run scored
great
so this is our dashboard space so it
says drop sheets here and then these are
our dashboards
and we have other objects down here
that you can also bring on
and then over here we have layout
which after you have brought things on
you can change their layout here
and it will show your item hierarchy
based on how they're nested down here so
on our dashboard
we will first bring in
our matches
and we will bring in our top scorers
and we have
all these different places for matches
our different cities for our top scorers
and so
if we go back to the sheet top run
scorer we can do that in three ways we
can come down and find the right sheet
and click on it to go to that sheet we
can look at our visualization and click
this go to sheet and it will take us to
that sheet
we'll go back
or we can come over here to our sheets
and click go to sheet and we'll take it
to that sheet so let's take our filters
off of the sum of runs so that we're
showing all runs for all cities
you know what instead
let's just edit it
so it's filtering out
only those
that never scored more than
say 100.
okay so we have a lot more in here but
it will filter out some of the lowest
ones
and we'll go back to our dashboard
and now there's one thing you can do
which is called
an action and so we can click use as
filter
and now when we click on a city over
here it will filter the remaining sheets
on this dashboard to
what you've selected so
we can see
how many matches have been done in
different cities and if we want to see
well who are our best players in mumbai
it will filter down to the top run
scorer
so that's called an action so let's get
rid of that
and we'll look at doing it manually as
well so here under dashboard we have our
actions and you can see there are no
actions in here
but then when i come and click uses
filter
then we go to dashboard and actions and
now we have an action called filter1
generated
and what that has done is made an action
based off of the matches in each venue
sheet
and it affects the other sheet
on select
and when you unselect see it says
clearing the selection will show all
values and it's doing it based on all
fields
okay
so if we wanted to make a different
action
which is a url action on these two
sheets when you
select
it'll take you to
this website
so this is the wikipedia beginning page
but let's say we wanted to take you to a
specific wikipedia page in wikipedia if
you append on
the name of the wikipedia page to the
end of this url it will take you
straight to that page
and we're going to assume that there's a
wikipedia page for all these different
cities
so we have city put in there
and
if we hit
okay
and now when we click on
city
then it will bring up the wikipedia page
for that city so if we come back and we
unselect that and then we come over here
and we pick
a different city
it'll do the same thing and bring up
that wikipedia page
so right now it's if you click on either
chart it will bring up the wikipedia
page
we can edit that
by maybe changing it
so that it's only when you pick it in
the top scorer
chart
so when you select something over here
it filters the top score chart but when
you select on something in the top
scorer chart it brings up that city
that's just an example and now it's
bringing up that
page on a separate screen so let's
there we go
now we're back
okay
and some more things that we can do
is
we'll get rid of this visualization that
is a legend for how big the circles are
and how what that means because we have
the labels right over top of the circle
so we don't need a legend for that we'll
close that
we have the capability of filtering on
city right now
but when we do filter on city
is only affecting this visualization and
not this visualization
so we can change that
by hovering over apply to worksheets and
then changing it to selected worksheets
and clicking all on the dashboard
and when i click show all worksheets in
the workbook you can see the rest of the
worksheets that are not on the dashboard
are not affected
on select okay
and now when i
filter these
it does it in both places
another thing we can do to make this
look a little nicer is make this a
multiple values drop down
so now it's in a drop down form
we can also
a horizontal
object
up here
and put city up inside of there
as kind of like a header
but we can have some more filters
so if we wanted to be able to filter by
the date
we can put the date on filter there
we'll click use all for now
let's go back to our visualization
we'll click on the visualization we
added it to and hover over filters
and look you can add year of date
here it is
let's put it up next to city
and we'll also change it to a multiple
value drop down list
and we'll also have it apply to selected
workbooks all on dashboard
okay
so now we can see
the different years
we only wanted to see maybe 2017 they
both apply
or they apply to both visualizations
there
and we can have those
and we can add a blank object
over here on the other side of city
so that it doesn't take up quite as much
space
we could put a text object up here too
with the
name of maybe the whole workbook or
the sheet
there it is but if we want to edit it
and we can make it bold and we can make
it big
those are some of the things we can do
to
update all of our
different dashboard things
our next dashboard the one that's going
to be about
overall performance
we're going to change it to automatic
again
and we're going to bring in
information about performance so we'll
bring in the leading batsman
and our leading bowler
our top five boulders will go underneath
the bowler information and our top five
batsmen will go underneath the batsman
information you can see that
any filters we had or any
different legends we had are showing up
here we don't need these legends because
we have the names right next to them so
let's get rid of those
when i clicked on
the bowler in that last visualization or
in the last legend it highlighted that
particular bowler so i had to unselect
it before i closed it out okay and then
we had batting teams filter here
which we will not use
but we will use this year filter and now
if i change it it will only affect this
visualization but i want it to affect
all so again
this is just a good habit to have to
make sure all of your filters affect
everything on the dashboard that you
want it to affect
and that it's very clear which ones it's
affecting
let's give it some space
we can move this whole
piece to along the top here
it doesn't need that much space
and we'll change this
to be a drop down
filter
and it doesn't need all the space
so we can add
some blank to either side
and have it a little bit more
in the middle here
so now
we just want to look at 2017.
we can see our leading batsman and our
leading bowlers but then you can't see
it over time anymore so let's
change our minds
and maybe we only wanted to apply to
worksheets these two worksheets
because we want these worksheets to
still show it over time
so if we click
selected worksheets and we remove our
top five top five
now we can see
that these worksheets update and these
ones do not
but one thing to keep in mind is that
these are the top five over all time
whereas these one two three four five
are the top five for this year
and so these top five are not the same
people you can see
as these top five well this one is
and this one is but it's going to change
and so that's the point
is that
it's important to recognize that these
top five could update
to just the top five for the year we
selected if we still had it applying to
these worksheets
so it's just your call
information over time when filtered to
just one period is
can be not very useful
so
our next dashboard
is going to be
about advantage
and we're just going to make it so that
we can see
the advantage
of the toss
and the advantage of batting just side
by side so let's add a blank up here
blank down here
and it just gives you a visualization
where you can see the advantage
of winning the toss at the advantage of
batting first one thing that we're
seeing here is that we're getting a
scroll bar because it's too wide to fit
in the selected area
so we could change
the visualization
to fit width
and then it will make this shrink to fit
inside the area instead of giving us a
scroll bar
we'll do the same thing here fit width
if we change it to entire view
then it will also change the height to
fill this area
entire view
there we go
today we're going to talk about building
dashboards in tableau based on
cricket data from the indian premier
league please comment below for access
to this data set and somebody from the
simply learn team will get back to you
and then you can follow along if you
have any questions about creating a data
source off of
a text data set so we're going to get
started and in this visualization we're
going to look at
batsman information so let me rename the
sheet and i'm going to call it all
innings
score
and so the
by the end of this we're going to have
two visualizations two dashboards one of
them focuses on batsman and one of them
focuses on bowlers some of the use cases
behind this is if you are trying to
figure out who did the best the batsman
and who did the best of the bowlers for
if you were trying to put together a
team so let's get started we're going to
look at batsman
and here we have listed out all the
batsmen we're going to make this
visualization so that you can look at
just one batsman at a time so i'm going
to right click on batsman and click show
filter and now we have a filter over
here with all of our batsmen and we can
choose just one or all of them let's
just look at one for now and then we're
also going to look at their information
across all of their matches
so we're going to bring on match id
and now we have all of the matches for
this batsman now we have quite a few
matches so we're going to allow them to
filter to just one season one year so if
i right click on date and click show
filter it gives me this automatic year
filter so we'll just filter to maybe
2014 and now we have all those matches
for one year for one batsman
and we want to look at the runs for this
batsman so we'll pull runs out here onto
rows and it now gives us bars for all of
those rows
if we were looking at multiple batsmen
so i select all here
it'll section them out by their names
but it's a little bit difficult to tell
where one batsman ends and one begins
sometimes just it's not that visually
easy even though there are lines so we
could make those lines darker or another
thing we could do is take batsman and
pull it onto color
and now each batsman gets their own
color and it's a lot easier to tell the
difference let's go back to just looking
at one batsman
and let's sort the matches from smallest
to biggest
and as in number of runs so here we have
all the runs for this batsman per match
if we look at multiple batman you can
see how he did as opposed to other
batsmen
there we go
let's
move on to our next visualization
it's going to be about
i'm going to click on the sheet click
rename and click type
type of dismissal
so now we're going to make a chart that
shows you
for one batsman for one
year
what kinds of dismissals they had so we
want the filters we made on all inning
scores over here to also apply to this
worksheet so let's talk about filters a
little bit when we right click on
filters we can click hover over apply to
worksheets and we have these options we
have all using related data sources all
using this data source or only this
worksheet and that's because we haven't
built a second worksheet yet we have
another worksheet but it doesn't have
the batsman information on it
cover right click on here same thing so
when i bring
or any information on this worksheet we
just need to have some information on
this worksheet for it to start being
taken seriously so i drag dismissal on
to color i go back to the sheet right
click and now we should have another
option
only this worksheet selected worksheets
all using this data source are all using
related data source we're going to use
the option selected worksheets now why
would we use the option selected
worksheet instead of all using this data
source this is because we're going to
apply these filters to all of the
batsmen worksheets but as i mentioned
before we're also going to make
visualizations based on the bowlers and
we're not going to use this same filter
on the bowlers worksheets so i'm going
to click selected worksheets
choose my worksheet and hit ok
i'll do the same thing here on year
apply to worksheet selected worksheet
and do the same thing
okay so
because of
filters and because how they can you can
have different filters per worksheet or
one filter that affects two worksheets
but not the other worksheets it's best
in my mind to do all of your filters at
the end when you're actually building
the dashboard so that you can keep track
of what the filter affects and what it
doesn't
in this case for our purposes we've done
it already
so now we're looking at just one batsman
just one year
but my preference is to do it at the end
now we brought on dismissal kind and put
it onto color and i want to make a pie
chart so i'm going to click on marks and
change it to pi and right now there's
nothing telling this visualization
how big each slice of the pie should be
so you need to drag something onto angle
let's first
make the pie bigger just so that we can
see it better and then let's also
remove the dismissal kind of null
so
we have
null dismissal kind and that's when the
batter batsman did not
get out
however we're trying to keep track of
how many times they did get out so this
isn't relevant so i right clicked on
null over here and clicked exclude what
that did was made a filter right here on
dismissal kind
and we click edit and you can see it's
excluding null so that's what right
clicking and clicking exclude did so
right now it's doing 15 50. it doesn't
know how big to make each angle and we
wanted to count the dismissal kind
and that's how it'll determine how big
to make each angle so i'm going to drag
dismissal kind on an angle and i get an
error why would i get an error i would
get an error because it's treating it
like a dimension and the dimension
is
by definition not something you use to
measure things with and so you can't say
this angle should be this big based on a
dimension
so we're going to change it to a measure
which is when we're going to count
the dimensions so
we're going to do a count of dismissal
kind so if they got out because they
were bowled out then we'll count how
many times that happened and that will
determine the red angle or the orange
angle
and if it was caught that will determine
the red angle so count
great so now we can see
five and six so
for
this batsman for this year
he was out 11 times
five times because it was caught five
times because it was bold
let's control
and drag dismissal kind on to label so
now we can quickly see the five and the
six and we're gonna control drag
dismissal kind on to label and we can
see
which kind
of dismissal it was that keeps us from
having to need this legend
so we can click hide card and we don't
need that anymore
now we're going to make another pie
chart based on runs so since i'm making
a second pie chart i'm going to
duplicate this
there are some pros and cons to
duplicating it one of the pros is when
we come up here to filters
and we come to selected sheets we can
see that the filters that applied to
type of dismissal are automatically
applied here onto type of dismissal too
and so that's great news because we do
want
it to be filtered to just one batsman in
just one year however we don't want it
to filter out dismissal kind of null
anymore because now we're looking at
runs and runs
need to have the times when they didn't
get out so we're going to pull dismissal
kind off
and if you weren't paying very close
attention or you copied it then you
might be confused as to why things were
getting filtered out but it was because
it copied your filters as well so that's
one of the disadvantages of copying
let's rename it
runs distribution
and i'm going to pull off all of this
information here so that we're starting
from scratch so here we have
basically blank pie chart
and we're going to
look at batsman runs
so there are a couple different kinds of
runs that you can get so i want batsman
runs to determine color but when i drag
batsman runs onto color it's doing a sum
of batsman runs
and it's just trying to make it darker
or lighter depending on how many runs
there were but that's not what i want i
want to use it as a dimension
and now we can see we have zero through
six
and that means that a batsman either has
zero runs or
one two
four or six runs
now there is three runs as well however
because we're only selecting
one year
and one batsman this particular batsman
for this particular year only had
either zero runs one run two four or six
so when we change it to a dimension it's
now instead of summing up all the runs
it is now just showing you their options
but it's still doing it like a scale
from light to dark i want six distinct
colors one for each so i'm going to
change it from a continuous
type of field to a discrete type of
field
and now i have 0 1 2 4 and 6. now i want
to exclude 0 runs because i'm not trying
to keep track of how many times they
didn't get a run i'm trying to keep
track of what how many times they got
different kinds of runs so again let's
exclude it and now we have our four
different kinds and just to show this i
right clicked on year i click show
filter
and if i show all the years you can see
our fifth kind
of run where they got three runs
on one ball
shows up so it does exist
it just didn't happen for this
particular batter or batsman during that
year now we want the angle to be
determined by
batsman runs
however we don't want to sum up the
batsman runs we don't want to take every
time that he got a six and do six plus
six plus six plus six what we want to do
is count how many times he got a six
so we're going to change it from a sum
to a count
and you can see he got
a six twenty four times
and so before let's go back
it was taking 24 and timesing it by 6
which is 144
and summing up
each of those times but instead we want
to count each of those times and see how
many times he got a six and how many
times he got a four not how many points
were scored
when um by getting a six so
that's a little bit of a confusing thing
to think about another thing you could
do is instead of doing a count of
batsman runs
let's pull that off you could use this
number of records field
and that will show us how many
meaning the number of records how many
records did we have from this batsman in
this year
that showed
that he batted a six so drag number of
records onto angle
and you see we get the same thing that
we had before so those are two ways of
doing it either change the
batsman
runs
to a count
or grab a number of records number of
records is a little bit simpler so let's
also bring number of records onto
the label and we can see
quickly that mostly he got ones
and got more fours than he got twos
actually which might is might be
interesting to
people who are trying to see how well
this batsman does our next visualization
has to do with the batsman's strike rate
so we'll make our new sheet
season
strike rate
and we'll need to make a calculated
field
to be able to determine the strike rate
for a batsman so
we'll come here to this arrow click on
it and click create calculated field
we'll call it strike rate
and we're going to find out how many
runs
that a batsman gets
basically for every 100 balls bold so
we're going to
get the total of the runs by doing a sum
of batsman runs
we're going to divide it by the number
of balls bold we know that this data set
is one row per ball bold
it's the ball by ball data so we're just
going to divide it by how many the
number of rows number of records
and we're going to put all of that
in parentheses
and one thing i need to do is instead of
just number of records i needed to be
the sum of number of records so that it
adds them all up before it divides it
okay so sum of the runs divided by the
sum of the bold balls and we will
multiply that by 100 and that is our
strike rate okay so now that we have our
strike rate we can start building our
visualization
we would like to have
both of these filters so i'm going to
quickly apply it
so first build the visualization and
then apply it we're going to
come here and bring date onto columns
and it's giving us one per year
we're going to change our marks card
no let's leave our marks card the way it
is and then we are going to bring on our
bowler
and we're going to bring on our strike
rate
next
okay
so
now that we have
kind of the beginnings of our
visualizations let's go here
and we can now apply it to our
new worksheet apply the existing filters
one of the reasons it's so important to
apply the existing filters
to our worksheet
there we go now we can see quickly see
his strike rate for 2014. i'm going to
control drag strike weight onto label
and we have it there as well
okay one of the reasons it's so
important to use the same filter
that is applied to all of the selected
worksheets
instead of just bringing batsmen back on
and making our new filter each time is
we want on the dashboard to just have
one filter that applies to all of them
so you can see here when i change this
to 2015
and remove 2014 and then we go to season
strike rate we can see this one's also
2015 now
and we'll go back to 2014
season strike rate and this one's also
2014. so we want whenever a filter is
changed for it to affect all of the
visualizations associated with our
dashboard and so all of our
visualizations that are about batsmen
and their information we want to be able
to use the same filters
so i'm going to click show filter
quickly
and we're going to see what happens to
this dot when i add more years
so this is going to allow them to see
the strike rate per 100 balls over time
if they select more periods
our next visualization
is going to be called
team versus
player
and we're going to see how many runs a
batsman scores against particular teams
so we're going to bring on bowling team
because that's the team the bassman is
against we're going to bring on
batsman
and their
batsman run
so now we can see how many runs each
batsman scored against all these
different teams
and again
we're going to apply our filters
there we go
let's also bring batsman onto color
again
just for when we're looking at multiple
batsmen at once in our filters
and we're going to bring the batsman
runs onto label
there we go so now we can
have it in both places instead of just
pulling it off and putting it on the new
one
great team versus player
and our last visualization for
the batsman dashboard
is going to be called
balls per boundary
so we're going to see how many
balls bold it takes for a batsman to get
a boundary
but
we have balls for per boundary
calculated here and also a boundaries
count calculated here
however we're going to show you how to
make our own versions of these
calculations so
i'm going to create a calculated field
i'm going to call it
boundaries count
and it won't let me save it as
boundaries count because i can't have it
saved as the same name
at least in tableau desktop that's true
i'm not
it looks like tablet public isn't
getting mad at me for that so but i'm
going to change the name
to
boundaries count calculated
so we can tell the difference between
the one that existed in the one that we
calculated
and we are going to
do an if statement so if
the batsman
runs
the individual batsman's runs not the
sum over whatever we select if batsman's
run is greater than or equal to
four
then one else
zero
so
it's giving me an error because i always
need to have an end
whenever i do an if statement
and this shows that whenever a boundary
happens so if they scored four or six on
one ball
then we'll count it one
otherwise zero and if i sum this up then
we'll be able to count how many
boundaries they had so
apply
okay
and for example if i brought on a
batsman all the batsmen
and i brought on boundaries count
calculated
this should be
counting up how many boundaries they had
overall time
so that's the numbers we're getting here
okay let's back it out now we're going
to make
our new calculated field called
balls per boundary
calculated
just so that it's clear which one is
which
and we're going to count
all the balls so this is for every ball
bold so we're counting the balls we
could also use the number of records
here similar to what we talked about
earlier and we're going to divide it by
the sum
of
the boundaries count calculated
so this will show us how many balls it
takes to get
a boundary apply okay
great now we can start building our
visualization
and we are going to bring on
batsman onto columns
and we're going to bring
balls per boundary calculated onto rows
and now it's showing us
how many balls it takes
for the boundaries let's also bring
batsman onto
color i've got to hold ctrl when i do
that
there we go
so we have batsman here and batsman here
and we're going to do the same thing
hold ctrl drag this down to label
now we can see the exact number
and for the final time
we're going to apply our filters
now i could have waited and applied my
filters at the very end once i had all
these built again i do recommend
applying your filters at the end
now we're going to put together the
first of our two dashboards so i'm going
to click on dashboard here
i'm going to change it to automatic size
which will fill my screen i'm going to
change it back to fixed size so now we
have our width and our height based on
what automatic size was
let's just round it out a little bit so
instead of
1678 i'm going to change it to be
just an even
1600 and same even 900.
so now we have
our fixed size here
there's also you could change it to a
laptop browser or a full screen so if we
click full screen
there's that size
generic desktop
i'm gonna go back to my size the size
that works for you is going to be based
on the size that works the best for all
of your users so that will take some
research
on your side and before i get started
i'm going to
do some formatting of my dashboard so
i'm going to click format here and i'm
going to change the default shading for
the dashboard
to
this particular
shade
you can use this color selector or all
these different kinds of basic colors
and so it just gives it a different
color than just the basic white so
that's a quick way to change the whole
dashboard color and i'm also going to
bring on
some text for the title of the dashboard
let's name our dashboard
we're going to call it batsman
performance
so
actually spell it out there okay and
then down here it says show dashboard
title so i'm going to select that and we
have batsman performance there at the
top
if you don't want the title here to
match what's here you have a couple
options so you can click edit title and
put in whatever you want
you can also
come we'll click floating here and we're
gonna just drag text on here
and
allows you to be able to make your own
title like that as well or just whatever
text you need to put on your dashboard
so we'll just remove that from our
dashboard and we're going to bring on
our visualizations
but we're going to bring them on as
floating visualizations
so i've selected floating here versus
tiled floating allows you to bring
something on and drop it and wherever it
lands is where it lands and you can move
it around and it's not going to try to
automatically fill this area
if i change it to tile
and i bring this on
it'll fill the area or
i'll put it to the left or the right and
it will fill those sides
so back to floating
floating has some benefits
where you can just drop things and they
will land there however
if you make it floating then you have to
adjust the size of each individual thing
instead of just say if we
brought it on
undo that as tiled and we brought on
this
and we brought on this if i wanted to
adjust the size of these things i can
just drag this little line in between
and it just tiles them and they fill the
space you give them
versus with floating
when i bring on this
and i bring on this
then i have to if i want to adjust the
sizes i can make this one smaller and
then i need to make this one bigger
independently of that
so there are some pros and cons of doing
it either way
but we are going to do it the floating
way
and we are going to bring on
team versus player first
and put it here
then we're going to bring on
underneath that type of dismissal
so basically all of our dashboards one
at a time
here's where our balls per boundary goes
my runs distribution goes over here
[Music]
and it brings in
whatever
filters you showed
at the time and all the legends that are
showing up on that visualization so if i
go back to runs distribution you can see
we had gear and that legend on there and
i brought them in as well
let's also bring on
season strike rate
also had here
and all inning scores
okay so this is the one that had all
ending score if you recall was the first
one we made that originally had our two
filters so we're going to change our
filters from multiple value list to
multiple value drop down
and that causes it to take up way less
space
it still has an incredible height so
we're going to go to layout and we're
going to change the height
to something more reasonable
100 just brings it onto the screen so
that i could drag it like that there we
go
and then
year of date
we're going to edit this one
let's see
to be multiple value drop down as well
and again
a more reasonable height for a multiple
value drop down okay so we've got
started
we have this legend here for color for
batsman which we're going to remove
because it has the name on it generally
and we're going to figure out how wide
we want these to be
so we need all three of them to fit
in
our width
so that would be
a width around 500 each so let's go to
layout here and we're going to change
the width from 533 to 500.
on each of these visualizations
and that gives us some extra
space to go in between them all
it's a little bit more reasonable the
space in between
there we go
and run distribution
so
once i've kind of figured out my spacing
to go in between them i can line up
these bottom ones by matching
the y
or x x value so this x is 25
and this one i wanted to line up with it
up and down so i'll change my x to 25
and it shifts it over
this one is 555
so i'm gonna change this one
and this one
i'm just going to copy and paste this
one
into this one
now we kind of have the x figured out
and i want them all to line up along the
y as well so i'm going to take this
and i'm going to apply the 170
to all three of these
so that they line up perfectly
this is another benefit of having it be
a floating object because on
a tile object you can't determine their
position exactly otherwise
it would mess up all the tiles around it
but you also don't need to put them
quite as precisely in order because when
you do tiled it kind of lines them up
along lines
as they are
tiled great so this is a lot more
straightforward
let's
get these
i'll get this guy about where i want it
and then i'll line this one up with it
up and down
there we go
um we can also
come here and edit the title and just
make the font a little bit bigger
on both of these
and now let's make the worksheets here
individually a little bit closer to the
color that we
picked for our background
so i'm going to click right click right
on top of the chart and click format
then i'm going to go to the shading
section and on the worksheet i'm going
to choose more colors you see the color
that we selected before for the
background is in this little palette of
recently used colors
and i want one slightly different than
that so i'm just going to enter in the
one that i want
and i'll copy that so i can use it on
the others
however if i did want the same color as
i had there i could just select it right
of the recently used colors okay
and there we go we'll come here
right click on the chart click format
shading and
i'm gonna paste in
that color
and you see when i clicked from here to
here it kept me right on that same sheet
however you see that this went to white
instead of the darker color i had before
and so
i don't even have to click format again
i can just come here
and paste in
my color
so i have a color that matches more
closely to my background color but it's
still different enough that i still have
the
outline kind of the shape of having like
cards on this dashboard
we go full screen here we now have our
dashboard that allows us to see
[Music]
all of the batsman performance
information for whatever batsman we
choose and whatever year we choose so
when we change the year
all the charts update
we want to
change the batsman
to
one of these chris's
there we go some of them aren't in the
year 2014 which is the problem we were
having there we go so now we see
all the same information but for chris
instead
so now that we've made our batsman
dashboard we're going to move on to
making our bowler dashboard
our first visualization for the bowler
is going to be called
buller performance
against team it's very similar to the
one that we made for batsmen only it's
showing how
the bowler has performed against batting
teams
and the wickets that they got against
those batting teams so
we're going to
bring on
the batting team
so we can see all the batting teams
against them
we're going to bring on bowler
so that it separates it out by bowler
one more try we'll also put bowler onto
color
and we're going to bring on
player dismissed
no sorry
we're going to bring on dismissal kind
we brought on dismissal kind but i want
to change it to be a measure and a count
of the dismissal kinds
and let's put it
here so now we have a bar chart
for the dismissal kind you can see that
it's going 0 to 30 for each of these
and that's because we have some that go
all the way up to 30 against a team
and if we wanted we could edit the axis
and change it to be independent axis
ranges for each row or column
so now we can see that it
is zero to two for this guy
but zero to thirty for this guy
and that can be nice
when
you want to be able to look at them
independently however when we're looking
at them side by side and you're trying
to compare
we would think that maybe this person
did just as good
as
somebody like
this person so we're not going to do
that
because it could be misleading
also in the end i'm going to have
filters so that we're looking at one
bowler at a time and one year at a time
so
we won't need
to see them all at once
okay
we have bowler on color let's also
control drag the count of dismissal kind
on the label so now it's labeled
some of them are going to have a lot
fewer against teams maybe they didn't
play as many seasons and that they might
have a lot more that's why we're going
to have the filter for a per season
number
but we're not going to do that right
away
okay
next workbook
and worksheet
and we're going to call it
bowler versus player
so when we're looking at this at one
bowler at a time we can see
how the bowler has done versus
particular players
so
we're gonna bring on the batsman
here
and then we're going to bring on
dismissal kind here and again we're
going to change it to
account measure
and we can count all the dismissals
against particular players when we
filter it down to one bowler we can see
how they did versus certain players and
then in just one year
let's sort
biggest the smallest
we're going to
bring batsman
onto color
and
that way when we switch from
bowler to bowler we could kind of see
which batsman fall in certain areas it
also just
makes it
quick to follow it along to the edge
and
we could put counter dismissal on the
label here
so that it's easy to quickly see however
when we filter it down to just one
bowler and one year then there's gonna
be a lot fewer dismissals per batsman so
it'll be pretty easy to see so let's not
do that let's go on to our next
worksheet
and this one is going to be called
bowling average
so we need to create
a bowling average calculation
it's going to be runs conceited per
wickets taken so we have to come up with
our runs conceded which is
all of the
batsman runs we'll sum those up and
divide it by
the number of wickets which is the count
of dismissal kind
and now we have our bowling average
there is a bowling average that already
existed so again we're going to call it
bowling average calculated
so that we know which one's ours
okay apply done
and
we're going to bring on the bowler
and bowler onto color
and let's bring on our bowling average
calculated
or assorted
biggest to smallest
it might be better to sort it smallest
to biggest
but some of these players might not have
played
or bowled
so that's why we'll have nulls
so
biggest smallest it is
and let's also bring the bowling average
that we made
onto
the label
great
our next sheet we will also need to
make a calculated field for this one
and let me hurry and name it and then
i'm going to go back to bowling average
because i had
one more thing to do there
economy
rate
is our next sheet okay so for bowling
average we have a situation where maybe
somebody doesn't know what the bowling
average means
so
you can right click on your chart in the
outside area outside of the graph area
and click on caption
and the caption will pop up and it's
automatically making a caption which is
bowling average calculated for each
bowler it's just describing what's
happening and then it says color shows
details about the bowler which it does
and the marks
are labeled by the bowling average
calculated
so when i double click on the caption i
can change it to be whatever i want
which i'm going to
put
runs
conceited
per
wicket
taken
and now we have a caption that kind of
is describing what this visualization
means
so on economy rate the economy is
defined as the number of runs conceded
for each over bold so instead of the
runs conceited per wicket taken it's for
each over so we're going to create our
calculated field we're going to call it
economy
calculated
again we have to get a sum of our runs
there's our runs we're going to divide
it by
the count
of the balls so this will tell us how
many
balls were thrown and but we don't want
how many balls were thrown we want how
many
overs there were
so just to make this a little more clear
i'm going to put parentheses around this
and we're going to take
there are six balls thrown in and over
so we're going to take the number
of balls and divided by 6
to get the number of overs so we'll take
batsman runs and then this is per over
hit okay
for this visualization it's going to be
pretty similar
to the last one
where we're going to bring on economy
and we're going to put economy onto i'm
going to hold ctrl
and put it onto the label
sum of economy
oh it's not even using my calculated
field so
economy calculated
there we go
now it's much more reasonable we'll drag
economy calculated onto label
and
since this dashboard is going to be
meant to be viewed one bowler at a time
we're going to not split it out by
bowler in this situation
but you could and if you do split it out
by bowler that means they could select
more than one bowler at a time and see
their economy side by side
also here we can see that it says
economy calculated for our label if we
hit edit axis we can change the title
so we're just going to call economy
probably need to do the same thing for
bowling average there we go
edit axis
bowling average okay it got mad because
i didn't close it and then there we have
it
again i'm going to
right click in some empty space and
click caption and then we have our
caption here
edit caption
and we're going to put
average
runs conceded
okay
there we go we have our caption we have
our chart
and we have one more visualization to
make
for our dashboard
remember if you have any questions or
comments please put them below and
somebody from the simply learn team will
help us answer those questions or if you
have an answer to somebody else's
question feel free to chime in we'll get
a good discussion going
the last one is called dismissal
and we're going to look at kind of like
we did before type of dismissal but this
was the batter and how they got
dismissed
whereas this is the bowler and how they
took the wicket so
we are going to also make a pie chart
which means dismissal kind goes on to
color and we change the marks to pie so
we have a pie that shows a color for
each of the dismissal kinds again let's
remove null so again i came over here
right clicked and clicked exclude but
you can do it right on the visualization
dismissal kind and you say it's blank
instead of bold or cotton bold
and click exclude there so there it
makes our filter next we need to
determine the angle size we're going to
bring on number of records
and the more
records that fall under that dismissal
kind that means the more often that kind
happened
and let's bring number of rows number of
records onto label as well
and
also
we're going to entire view
so that it's nice and big and easy to
read and we're going to
add a
caption and
we're just going to put
dismissal types
but we'll see how that comes up on the
visualization so now that we have made
all of our
visualizations for our dashboard let's
add our filters so just on this last one
i'm going to bring bowler onto filter
and we're going to click use let's
actually select a bowler
you can use this box to search
there we go and it's popped up you see
how i didn't even have to start
searching it at the beginning of the
name
it's just smart enough so we have our
bowler
let's bring on date
we're going to choose years
and let's use 2016
and we have our year
and now let's apply it
to all the worksheets that it applies to
so dismissal economy rate bowling
average bullying versus player and
bowler performance against team
same for a year
okay and you can see how much quicker
that is to
apply
instead of doing it every time you make
a new dashboard
so much quicker saves you some time can
be confusing so make sure you do it
because if you forget to do it and then
you change a filter on a dashboard and
it only changes one of the
visualizations on that dashboard then it
can be really confusing and
like on the batsman performance if we
had forgotten to add these to all the
visualizations and we left it off of
this visualization then
people could be confused as to why
that's not changing or off of this
visualization if it's not changing it's
hard to know if it's not changing
because it didn't change from year to
year maybe his types of dismissal were
the same from year to year
or
it's just hard to tell the difference
and see if it's not affecting it so
always be sure
to double check
that your filters are applied to
everything you need them to be applied
to
let's make a dashboard
okay
we're going to make it
what we made it before
sixteen hundred by nine hundred
and you can see all of our sheets are
showing up but let me show you a quick
trick here this dashboard uses all of
the batsman sheets and we don't use any
of the batsman sheets again inside of
the second dashboard so if i right click
on the batsman performance and i click
hide all sheets it doesn't hide all
sheets it just hides all sheets
associated with that dashboard
and now you no longer see those sheets
and when i come to dashboard 2 it's only
showing me the sheets that are not
hidden
for that dashboard
let's get started by first changing our
dashboard color so i came to dashboard
and i hit format
and i'm going to change the color to
this blue color
and there's our background
and then i'm going to click
show dashboard title which is dashboard2
right now so let's rectify that right
now and we're going to call it
fuller performance
and here we have bowler performance
let's do floating which is already
selected
and we're going to bring on bowler
performance against team
and we're going to go side by side with
bowler versus player
and it's brought on
both of these have brought on
legends that are actually not helpful
because we have labels that tell us
these things so we're going to get rid
of these legends
sometimes i wait till i brought i have
brought on all of my dashboards before i
remove legends or change filters so
all of our all of my worksheets
sometimes i wait till i've brought on
all my worksheets i'm gonna bring on
bowling average
and economy rate
and dismissal
here's an actually useful legend so
we'll keep that around
remove this legend
because right there just tells you right
next to it
and now let's start adjusting our charts
so i'm going to make
these two side by side up here so they
need to split the space
so let's try a width
of
which gives you a little bit of space
side to side
but still uses the space a little bit
better
you can see that this visualization is
too tall to fit inside of the area we've
given it so it has a scroll bar here on
the side
if you change
how this fills in its space so right now
it's standard you can have fit width
which it's already fitting the width of
the area that is provided if you do fit
height it's going to force everything to
fit inside of that area so there's no
scroll bar and it does not look good for
this visualization
and an entire view it's the same thing
it's trying to make everything fit
inside that area so we're going to go
back to standard another one that's good
for things where you do want the scroll
bar up and down is fit width so either
of those look good um these two are
going to share space underneath this one
and so i'm going to make them
both
let's say
3 300
how does that look oh that's good
let's make this one the same size as
this above it
750.
bring it over
okay
you notice
one thing
that's happening here is
we cannot see at this point the filters
there are no filters popping in here
even though we added filters now why
would that be that's because we have no
filters being shown on our visualization
none of our worksheets showed the
filters they just existed here so
if we come and we click on one of our
visualizations click the drop down arrow
and we go to filters we can see all the
filters we can select from
we're going to bring on bowler
let's make it
the drop down
and again
it's just made it a really unreasonable
height because i was trying to fit all
of those bowlers
but 20 is too small
there we go
and we'll go here
and also bring on
year of date
what's the height on this one
55 55 is a good height
now it's time to clean it up a bit
so we have all of our pieces
let's first make sure when i change this
that
everything changes so when i unselect
2016 they should all
go to null and i click fit 2015 they all
update
that's what we want to see
okay so we have all the pieces we just
need to get them lined up looking nice
and
just getting things a little bit more
clean
like here
we want to show our caption
that we added
and here
so this kind of is something that you
can use on your dashboard to
describe things that are happening
or different pieces of it it's just an
easy way
to add a caption and then let's line
them up up and down i think that we
could probably make both of these a
little taller
what do we think about 350
maybe even 400
and we'll bring
these ones down
that's really nice for this
visualization to have more space
just a little bit more space whatever
you can give it honestly
is really helpful
sometimes with these visualizations that
are up and down i like to give them the
whole side to themselves so maybe we
would move this over and make it smaller
and these all three would fit right here
and then i'd give this one all this up
and down space i'll undo that
we can move this legend over a little
bit more
there we go
and then let's start lining things up i
like where this one is positioned
on the y-axis so i'm going to copy that
and bring it over here
they were pretty close there we go
and then
i'm going to
do the same thing with the y-axis for
these ones
just to make sure they're perfectly
lined up
these it looks like i could make a
little bit wider
if you would like
one thing that's happening here is it
looks a little bit like this one has
more up and down space than this one
does
and that's because it's missing this
label and it also isn't colored the same
as these other ones as it represents the
bowler well we can fix that because if
you remember we did not put bowler onto
the columns and we put it on there
there's our label
we also didn't put it onto color and
there we go so that gives us a little
bit more consistency
between these two visualizations
however they're still labeled economy
rate and bowling average with their
captions at the bottom there
okay
and since these are the same width i
would like to line them up on the x-axis
so
i'm going to take this
there
and that lines those up i want to make
sure that these are lined up
up and down pretty close but not quite
there
there we go and also year of date
is not necessarily what i want
the update part is
just
not useful for what we need so i'm going
to change it to year i'm also going to
center it
we'll come here for bowler
and center that one as well
center and also let's make it a little
bigger
see how it did not make it bigger that
is because the formatting
in here
such as changing the font or bolding it
requires you to have whatever text you
want selected
so now it's bigger
there we go
i like the white on the blue so i won't
change these individual dashboards
or individual worksheets to be a
different color
let's take a look
here we have our second dashboard
if we come here and we click hide all
sheets now you can only see the two
dashboards
in these tabs at the bottom
and you can see that we can have
different years for the two different
dashboards you could tie the year
together
oh we have year of date on this one too
let's change that
so
that's not
what i meant to click there we go edit
title
we're going to make it centered we're
going to make it bigger
don't press enter
when you're not done
and we're going to erase update so
that's just year
do the same thing over here
this just adds a little bit of
consistency
there are two separate dashboards
but if if people are going to look at
them
side by side maybe or one right after
the other it is nice to have some
consistency
there we go
so there you have it we have made two
dashboards
one of them about batsman performance
one of them about baller performance
during this time we learned about
formatting our dashboards we learned
about floating versus tiled
and about
positioning legends and filters some of
the options we have for changing filters
today we'll be going over answers to
common interview questions for tableau
positions first question is what are the
data types supported in tableau we have
string date date and time numerical
boolean so true or false and
geographical in tableau you can tell
what kind of data type you have so when
you're on the data source tab you can
see that this is numerical and this is
string here we have a date we don't have
any date times here that would have the
little clock icon and we also have
geographical these are set by default
and you can change them by clicking on
the icon
and say we wanted row id to allow text
so we'll change it to string and you can
see the icon changes there the next
question has to do with how will you
understand dimensions and measures so a
key thing to remember is that dimensions
are qualitative and measures are
quantitative and if you can remember
those particular words it helps convey
what the interviewer is looking for so
dimensions are qualitative and you can
use them to categorize your data so for
example you can categorize your data by
what country it comes from and measures
are quantitative and can be aggregated
so you can do a sum of sales or you can
do the average profit did you know that
tableau automatically assigns each field
a data type and a role and that
automatically aggregates your measures
using sum but you can change what the
default aggregation is question three
what do you understand by discrete and
continuous in tableau so we have
discrete values and continuous values
discrete is represented as blue and
continuous is represented as green so
let's look in tableau when we go to our
worksheet
you can see that all the dimensions are
automatically blue
and all of the measures are green
however you can have a continuous
dimension and you can have a discrete
measure
so we have discrete dimensions which is
a blue dimension but also continuous
dimensions and data is a good example of
that let's take a look so we pull on
order date we right now have year
and it's making categories instead of a
continuous axis so it's making a finite
list there but we can change it to be
you can see now it's marked as
continuous here and it's green and we
change it to be an axis
instead of different categories it would
be a continuous axis
so you can also have discrete measures
which are blue measures and continuous
measures in the green so for example
let's say we had a visualization that
had
the region
and
sales
and profit
but instead of having an access for
profit maybe we just wanted to have
a number for the profit listed right
next to the region and then we could
have the sales visualization so what we
could do
is change it to a discrete
value and put it next to region and now
it's part of the labels
and that's an example of having a
discrete
measure
did you know that
continuous is infinite and discrete is
finite those are some key words that you
could use also to describe the
difference between continuous and
discrete and also just remember that
discrete is blue and continuous is green
the next question number four is what
are filters and name the different
filters in tableau so filters are a way
to restrict the data that allows you to
only see the data that you want to see
in your workbook or dashboard and there
are these different types of filters and
they also have a specific order so if
you can remember the different filters
that's helpful but also if you can
remember what order they apply in
that'll get you some definite bonus
points in your interview we have extract
filters that filter the data as it
extracts and it will affect how big your
extract is we also have data source
filters here which will filter the data
out of the data source however the
extract will still be the same size so
let's take a look at this handy
visualization
that tableau has on their website we
have the order of operations and in blue
we have our filters
so extracts is first and it filters down
your extract to just what you've
selected and we have data source filters
that will apply to the entire data
source so any visualization that uses
that data source will have these filters
we also have context filters which are
next which come before
some of these level of details that's
the major difference is that it applies
before some of these sets and
conditional values and then you will do
dimensions and then measures so any
filters that happen on dimensions happen
before any measure filters the last type
of filter we have is a table calculation
filter which happens after all of the
rest of them and basically just applies
to
your visualization just the one
visualization question number five there
are three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits is associated with the
corporate segment perfect so in some
tableau interviews you may be asked to
build a visualization for our examples
here we'll be using the superstore
dataset and if you don't have access to
the superstore data set just comment
below and somebody on the simply learn
team will help you get access to that
also this is a fun opportunity to pause
the video and then you can work on this
on your own and then come back and see
if what you did was the right thing or
how we did it differently also you can
comment below on what your answer is and
we'll see if we can all get the right
thing
so let's build this
three customer segments in the
superstore data set what percent of the
total profits total profits is
associated with corporate segment great
so we're going to bring on our segments
and we have consumer corporate and home
office and let's bring on our
total profit so i just did that by
double clicking
and now it's just bringing on the sum
for each of those by default but we want
to figure out what percent of the total
each of these are so we can change this
to be
a table calculation we can click add
table calculation or we can do a quick
table calculation
and find percent of total so let's go
back to our question we wanted to know
the percent of total profits associated
with the corporate segment and the
corporate segment has
32.12 percent of the total profits and
here's our solution with
32.12 percent so did you get it right
comment below if you got that what are
the different joins in tableau give an
example
so in
tableau you can join your data so if we
wanted to look at orders and tie it to
people we could pull on people and it
will give you this visualization and you
can see all the different joins here and
we'll discuss those in just a second you
also have the opportunity to union
information which would be if we had
maybe two excel sheets that had orders
information
perhaps one of them had 2012 and one of
them had 2013 then you could take your
orders and pull it so you see that
pop-up drag table to union and that's
another way to add more data and so
those are all worth mentioning let's
take a look at the different kinds of
joins
we have our inner join which will only
give you the values that have matches in
both tables
our left join that will give you all the
values in the left table and its matches
in the right table
and then the right join which will give
you all the values in the right table
and its matches in the left table
the outer join also known as a full
outer join will give you all the values
in the left and the right table
and then as we discuss the union you can
see it's represented by a more vertical
join and what it does is it adds more
rows all the rest of these are about
adding more columns but this will add
more rows
in the same columns that you had before
if you have the opportunity to draw out
the answer to this question and make
these venn diagrams it's a really
helpful way for you to explain your
point and it really portrays that you
know what you're talking about what is
the difference between a join and
blending in tableau so i just showed you
how to make a join here and we are
joining
an excel sheet
to another excel sheet all within the
same connection to that excel file
so when you're joining data we'll look
over here at the joining side that's
when you're bringing two or more tables
within the same data source and that's
how you join it and so um we're all
inside of a data source here which when
i go to sheet 1 just has one data source
here called orders whatever we wanted to
call it and that is all within one data
source however let's say we already had
two different data sources in tableau
and we wanted to bring together two of
them so in this case it's an oracle
table and we brought in an oracle table
and we made a data source and then also
an excel table that had a second data
source and you can blend it together to
get your combined data set so the major
difference what you're going to really
want to take away from this is that
blending is from two separate tableau
data sources and that
joining is all within one data source
and it ends up just being one data
source in the end in blending each data
source contains its own set of
dimensions and measures and when you
join it will combine it into one set of
dimensions and measures so let's go back
to our example here let's bring on
people it is automatically said we're
going to join it on region and we're
going to do an inner join that's fine by
me
and so we come here
and now we have just one
set of dimension and measures under
orders however if we were to add a
second data source which we will it will
be an excel file and it will be based
off of this rank example
we'll open that up and now when we go to
sheet 1 we have two data sources
and if we were to blend this data
together
we would still see two separate sets of
data only we would be able to pull in
from this set some information and we'd
pull in from this set some other
information so that's a visual
difference between blending and
joining question number eight is what is
the difference between a live and an
extract so first we'll talk about live
and we'll say that your dashboard is
connected live to a database and so a
live connection will query that database
every time you open up the dashboard or
visualization so that you're getting the
most recent information each time and
it's useful for if you need information
that's a little bit more real time
however it can be slower especially if
your queries are complicated with an
extract it will run the query beforehand
and store the information on tableau
server or on your local machine and so
that it's faster to get to however it is
not real-time information so if you had
a refresh of your extract that runs
every day in the morning and then during
the day somebody has made a change to
your database they won't see that change
on your dashboard until the next time
the refresh runs for your extract in
tableau
you can set
if you want the connection to be live or
extract when you first are making your
data source and this is a tableau
desktop in tableau
public you don't have that option did
you know that
that the reason that extracts are faster
is because tableau doesn't need to
access the database each time it builds
the visualization and did you know that
you can set up a refresh schedule on
tableau server in order to be able to
see your extracted data update
question 9 what is a calculated field
and how will you create one so if we
look at our data set here
we have the opportunity to see the
difference between order date and ship
date so to create a calculated field
you click create calculated fields with
this drop down arrow at the top or you
can right click in white space
create calculated field
then you give it a name
and we're going to call it
shipping delay
and we are going to do
[Music]
a date diff so if you don't see this
dialog box here you can click this arrow
to see that
our date part is day the start date is
order date and the end date is ship date
so to remember
how to create a calculated field it's by
clicking this down arrow and clicking
create calculated field
and then writing your
query here
and a calculated field is an additional
field made up using the data that you
already have so
we've made a new field here and it has
the equal sign at the beginning that
might be worth mentioning how to tell if
it's a calculated field or if it was an
original field and then we can bring a
shipping delay
here and we can see the number of days
that it took between the order date and
the ship date we could also
duplicate a calculated field so now we
have shipping delay copy
and we're going to call this
average shipping delay
and we're going to encapsulate it
inside an average function
and now if we take off the order id the
order date and the ship date
it's automatically summing up those days
but we can bring on our average shipping
delay
and you can see on average how many days
it took
and let's change
our number here to
include decimal places
so a calculated field is a new field
made from existing data
it can be used to create more robust
visualizations and it does not affect
the original data set for example we
made our average delay function here
using data from our original data set
question 10 how can you display top five
and last five sales in the same view
you can show top five and last five
sales for a same dimension by creating a
set
so let's take a look at doing that here
we have
our customers so let's bring on customer
name
and we're going to do it based on profit
so now that we've done it on profit we
can see these are our top five profit
and i've sorted it by profit
and
here's our bottom five
and we can create a set by coming and
clicking on the dimension that we want
the set to be based on we'll right click
there
and we will
come to create and click set
we're going to call this top customers
top buy field top 5
buy sum of profit and now we have a set
it makes a set section here
now we're going to make a second set
off of customer name
create set
bottom customers
bottom
5 by
sum of profit we'll hit ok
and now we're going to combine these two
sets so i'm going to control click and
then we have both of them selected and
we're going to click create combined set
top and bottom
customers
and we're going to have it include all
members of both sets
and now we can pull top and bottom
customers onto filters
and you can see our top five and our
bottom five so if we control drag profit
onto color
then it's colored by that as well so key
thing to remember is that you can use it
sets to create to show both the top and
the bottom in the same visualization and
that you can combine those sets
is there a difference between sets and
groups in tableau the answer to this is
yes
you can describe a group as being
simpler and using only one dimension to
determine the group whereas a set can be
more complex so you could say sets are
more complex and you can use conditions
to create the sets and you can also use
multiple dimensions and measures to
create the sets
for example here we create a group of
subcategory so we grab all of these
things together and can group it and
that will be
we'll have copiers and envelopes and
then we'll have one group
of all of these together
over here you could create a set
that looks at sales and profits to
create its set so the best way i can
describe this is by looking at what we
did here
and so we were able to use dynamic
filtering here to create our sets
and where we'll look at the top five or
the bottom five and let's do the same
thing we did there but use a group
so for a group we could see that these
we've sorted it and we can say
one two three four five this is the top
five so we could create
a group that's this paper clip here and
now we have a group of the top five and
it's added that group it makes a new
group customer name group and it put it
on the color for us now let's go to the
bottom and we're going to go one two
three four five and we'll create
our group
so now we have a top five group at
bottom five group so let's name them
that and we'll do that by clicking edit
alias
top customers
okay and we'll come here and we'll
rename that
bottom
customers
okay we'll put our top customers on top
and then let's hide all the others so
we'll click exclude there and now we
have a similar visualization as we had
before for our sets
top bottom however a key difference here
is that we had to go through and select
the top five and the bottom five so
let's say that
maybe
cindy or let's say henry goldwyn has
suddenly
had much more positive profit associated
with them if that changes he's going to
still stay in our group this group is
just using these customer names to
determine who's in the group
so the group is henry cherelle luke
grant and cindy no matter if their data
changes so say tomorrow all this data is
different it's still going to put these
people into the group however the sets
as you saw before is based off of the
profit the sum of profit and who has the
top five and who has the bottom five if
freeman suddenly has
a lot less profit and falls out of the
group then
the groups won't pick it up but the sets
will so that's one thing to remember is
that it could be based on conditions and
then you saw how we took two sets and
put them together into our combined
group you could also have a set that is
based off of two different dimensions
or two different measures and that's how
you could put those two sets together
and get dynamic sets
so the major differences as we saw is
that a group is just based off of one
dimension
and a set can have conditions and be
based on off of other dimensions
also you need to know that groups cannot
be used in calculated fields but sets
can
question 12 what is a parameter in
tableau and give an example
a parameter is a dynamic value that a
customer could select
and you can use it to replace constant
values in calculations filters and
reference lines so for example here we
determined we wanted bottom five and top
five customers but let's give them some
options so we'll create a parameter
and we'll call it select
number of
top
bottom
customers
and we're going to
[Music]
let it be a range
with a minimum of five
and a maximum of
and a step size of five so we'll let
them go five at a time
okay
now if we click show parameter control
we can see our parameter control and you
can do 5 10 15 or 20. but since it's not
in any of our calculated fields or sets
or filters then it's not making any
difference so let's put it inside of
these
we'll edit our set and instead of top or
bottom five
we'll click bottom select number of top
bottom customers so now it's taking our
parameter and inserting it in
to our set there we'll do the same thing
with top customers
okay and now right now we see top five
bottom five if we change it now we see
top ten bottom 10 15 and there's our 20.
so it replaces a constant value and
allows the end user to select the value
question 13 what is the difference
between tree maps and heat maps
so let's first talk about what each of
these are
heat maps compare categories using size
and color i think the biggest thing
about heat maps is the color size is
somewhat optional so let's build this
visualization quickly
so
we have region
category
and subcategory
and we're making a heat map so we want
to bring profit onto color
and you can see we've got hotter and
colder in this case
for a heat map we might want to change
so in this case what it's doing is
hotter is negative but we could reverse
that and then hotter is positive and so
hotter maybe means this is where more
activity is
we can also double click on profit
we can also bring profit onto label
and we'll change this to
square and now it's marked at what
everything is so a heat map
will use color to draw your eye to the
places where there's heat or maybe
activity we could also use size in this
case so it's not just defined by color
necessarily maybe we want the size to be
defined by sales so we get things that
are bigger but they're blue which means
that they are bigger in sales but their
profit is negative and it draws your
eyes to
technology so machines in the south are
doing a lot of sales but they're not
having positive profit necessarily
also you can see some things that have
darker colors
but are smaller so high profit but not a
lot of sales so that is a heat map a
tree map is used to represent
hierarchical data now hierarchy is the
term you need to remember when you're
talking about the difference between a
tree map and a heat map
in the heat map
none of these boxes have to do with the
hierarchy with each other whereas with a
tree map you can see that this box has a
thick white line between it and the
other ones and that means that that
section are all connected so these are
all technology
and the bigger this section is that
means the bigger the let's see size is
based off of profit so this bigger
section means that technology has more
profit than furniture so let's build
this one when i build tree maps i like
to use our show me tool so here's tree
map and it says one or more dimensions
or one and one to two measures so we're
going to grab category and we're going
to control click subcategory and we're
going to control click profit and
sales and we'll click on our tree map
perfect and so the darker the color
that means the more sales there is and
that's pretty similar to our heat map
over here so the color indicated
in this case it was profit so the color
indicates the difference and the size
indicates the difference and that's true
over here the color indicates a
difference and the size indicates a
difference however there is a hierarchy
to it over here you can see that there
is um hierarchies because we have
furniture and then that puts that all
together under furniture
and then here's the subcategories
however if you were trying to compare
furniture to office supplies it's really
difficult to tell which one has more
sales but if we go over to sheet 7 that
has our tree map on it you can see
really quickly that office supplies has
much more sales
than furniture in this case office
supplies has much more profit than
furniture biggest difference is that
tree maps have the hierarchy question
number 14 what is the difference between
twbx
and twb so these are all
tableau file formats and the twbx
contains all of the unnecessary
information to build the visualization
so it's called a packaged workbook
and it compresses it all together
however the twb just contains
instructions about how to interact with
the data source so when it's building a
visualization tableau will look at the
data source and then build the
visualization with an extract it
contains all of the information that you
need so all the data is wrapped up
inside of there and there's no
connection that has to be made between
tableau and the data source because it's
all right inside whereas with the twb it
has to connect to the data source or
else it doesn't have the data to build
the visualizations it just knows it has
the instructions of what to do with that
data so the biggest difference is twbx
has the data inside of it whereas a twb
only has the instructions question 15
explain the difference between tableau
worksheet dashboard story and workbook
perfect here's a breakdown and
explanation of each of those and in
tableau this entire thing that we've
been looking at all these sheets is a
workbook
however this sheet 7 is just one
worksheet all of them together is a
workbook and sheet 7 is a worksheet the
big difference between a worksheet and a
dashboard is that the worksheet is just
one
visualization and so it is only one set
of columns and rows here and a dashboard
could contain multiple visualizations so
if we wanted to see our heat map and our
tree map
on the same page that would be a
dashboard and then a story
is somewhat similar
to a presentation mode and so you can
have different pages and so we could say
here is our
heat map and then we could make another
page
and look at our
tree map
and then look at our heat map
and then we could duplicate that page
and we could
say let's focus on furniture
so we're going to highlight furniture
and then so if we were to go through
these one at a time
we would say
here's your tree map and then we would
look at information there and we would
say here's our heat map and then the
next screen will say let's focus on
furniture and you can see that it
highlighted furniture for me when i went
to the next seat so a story
can show you things one at a time it's
like a presentation mode so the
differences are the workbook contains
the sheets and the dashboards of the
stories
the worksheet is a single view
dashboard is multiple views and a story
is a sequence a sequence is a good key
word to remember when you're describing
a story and did you know that the only
place that you can access the dimensions
and the measures and custom fields we've
made is on a worksheet so when you're
looking at a dashboard
so on a worksheet we see dimensions and
measures when you're looking at a
dashboard you no longer see dimensions
and measures what you do see are all of
the worksheets similarly when you look
at a story you no longer see
any dimensions and measures but you do
see all the worksheets and the
dashboards
question 16 what do you understand by
blended axis with a blended axis you can
use two measures that share an axis and
that means they necessarily have the
same scale so let's build something with
a blended axis
so we can make a visualization
that
looks at
sales
over time
we'll bring on order date
and let's just
do order date by
month there we go
so we can see sales over time and say we
wanted to
also see profit
this is two visualizations that have two
different axes but if we wanted them to
have the same axes
and just the same marks card you see how
i made two different marks cards we
could bring on
measure values and take off all the
measures that we don't want
we just want
when we take them off here it's creating
this filter here for measure names
and let's take off these two extra
visualizations and now we have a
visualization that has a blended axes
for sales over time and profit over time
and you can see that they necessarily
have the same axes there is no second
axes what is the use of a dual axis and
how do you create one perfect so dual
axis allows you to compare measures and
you can have two different scales so if
we had this same visualization that same
information that we wanted to see with
again
profit
and sales
over time
we'll do
okay great and we wanted them to have
the same axes we could right click on
the second pill
of the measures
and click dual axis and now you can see
that they do not
share the same axis and you can see
profit is much higher here right there
and so the use of this would be
sometimes you need things to have
different axes
if you come here and you click
synchronize axes you end up getting a
pretty similar visualization but you do
get two separate marks cards
so a key thing to bring up if you are
asked the difference between a blended
axis and a dual axes chart
is
one that the blended axis uses the same
scale and a dual axis could have two
different scales and two a dual axis has
two marks cards so let's say we wanted
our profit
to not be a line chart but to be a bar
chart that gives you that option when
you go to the blended axis we only have
one mark's card so we change it to bar
everything is bar
but back over here we change it to
circles and we see the circles
so if we wanted to show sales by year
and profit ratio by year in the same
view that's where two different scales
could be handy let's build that
visualization
so we'll make a new chart
and we'll bring on sales
and
profit ratio
over time
that is profit i still did profit so
i'll drag profit ratio right over top of
profit there we go and you can see that
they can't use the same scale because
this is a percentage and so
if we had them on a blended axis 20
percent is really 0.2 and it would just
be so tiny
but if we wanted them on the same area
to act to
apply to the same space here we could
dual access it that you can still see
useful information there but otherwise
this would just be in such a tiny tiny
space so our profit ratio would just
show up right here almost like a
straight line
question 18 what will the following
function return
left three comma tableau here's the
question again and here are the
potential answers tab
or eau error or none of the above so
just take a moment and see if you can
answer this question correctly go ahead
and pause the video and if you get the
answer you can comment below and then we
will discuss
we've taken some time to answer this
question
and let's go ahead and see what the
answer is the answer is it will return
an error that's because the syntax for
our left is that the string must go
first
first you say left then you put the
string and then you put the number so
let's talk about what left does it
returns a specific number of characters
from the left and if you had done it
correctly the left is this side so if
you had done the string first and you
said you want three the result would be
t a b there's also one called right
and that would come from the other end
and go eau so that's where these answers
came from question 19
how do you handle null and other special
values tableau is unable to plot null
values or zeros or negative values on a
logarithmic axis
and so it will display an indicator in
the lower right corner which looks like
this
telling you that is unable to draw those
two points
so when you click on the indicator you
can choose from the following first you
can choose to filter the data which will
exclude the null values from the
visualization or you can click show data
at the default position so we'll look at
both of these
so you click on your indicator and it
will say what do you want to do with
these two values if we click filter the
data then you can see that it has
filtered those that blank space and
drawn a line connecting
those dates in between even though there
is no point for the 29th or the 30th it
goes straight from the 28th
to the 31st so what's happening on our
visualization is it's adding this filter
if we press the back button we see that
filter disappears if we come down and
select filter the data it adds a filter
here
that then
only includes non-null values
so those are all removed from our
visualization and up to this point you
can see that we have one point per day
the 21st the 22nd 23rd 24th but then
when we get to the 28th we don't have a
29th or 30th and it just draws that line
to the 31st
assuming
that during that time period
that what we want is a straight line
now the other option would be
we could also make the assumption that
whenever there is a null value that
actually means zero sales have happened
during that time so that's when you
would click show data at default
position
and now it draws those two points
at the zero line
and when you hover it still shows sales
null
so and when you hover here you can see
the actual amount for sales during that
time
so if a null in your data means zero
then show a default position is good for
you and if it doesn't necessarily mean
zero
then you can
filter the data or you can leave it
disconnected like this
question 20 find the top product
subcategories by sales within each
delivery method which subcategory is
ranked number two for first class ship
mode if you'd like to pause the video
and work on this on your own and then
see if
what you did matches what we did then
you're welcome to now at this time and
comment below what your answer is
okay
so we want to know by
subcategory and by ship mode
which
subcategory ranks the highest for each
ship mode so in sales so if we take
sales
onto the visualization we can see that
by the ship mode
it's already split up and we could see
that
maybe this one for standard class it
would be chairs you can kind of look
through and kind of oh it's not chairs
chairs isn't number one because we have
this one it's phones so to make it
easier we're going to
change some of sales to a rank table
calculation so we're going to come here
and click add table calculation
and we're going to change the
calculation type to rank and it's going
to rank them
in order
of sales
so but we right now we can see that it's
highlighting that's called calculation
assistance helping us understand
how it's ranking us so if i and select
calculation assistance then it gets rid
of it but you can see right now it's
ranking it
across the table so it says accessories
has most sales in standard class then
second class then first class then same
day
and that's not what we want to see we
want to see it up and down
we want to see for first class which
subcategory has the highest sales and
second highest sales so let's turn back
on our calculation assistance and we're
going to click table down
and you can see now it's going up and
down within first class what are all the
subcategories ranked so that's what we
want now as soon as you click things in
the table calculation it applies it over
here so you don't have an ok button
so you can just close that out
and you can see now we have a rank up
and down
for the subcategory so back to the
question was which subcategory is ranked
second for first class ship mode here's
first class let's find number two it's
chairs
question number 21
find the customer with the lowest
overall profit what is his her profit
ratio let's go ahead and build this
visualization
customer profit
and we're going to
bring all of our customers on
and then we're going to bring on profit
let's do it as a visualization so i'll
bring it on to columns
and then let's sort smallest to biggest
so cindy stewart
is the one who has our lowest profit
and now to figure out her profit ratio
we need to make a calculated field which
i've already made here
so in this calculated field we take the
sum of profit and divide it by the sum
of sales we do this
so that it will sum up all of the profit
per row
so for cindy we want to take all of her
profit
over all of her transactions and divide
it by all of her sales instead of doing
it row by row profit divided by sales
profit divided by sales and then summing
that up at the end so
we'll take our profit ratio and put it
on the label
and we can see what her profit ratio is
and since it's a ratio here i have it in
a percent
if you don't have your profit ratio set
up as a percent it will look like this
negative 1.65 question number 22
what is the rank function in tableau we
got a look at the rank function earlier
when we figured out our top product
subcategories by sales and what was
ranked number two so
i'm sure you're familiar with what
ranking is which is assigning something
a position like first place or second
place usually within a category and
usually based on a measure so
tableau is able to rank in several
different ways where you can do
rank or rank dense rake modified or rank
unique and we'll take a look at these
individualization here and talk about
the difference but if you are asked
about
the rank function in tableau it's worth
bringing up that there are several
different ways to rank and going into a
little bit of detail on those different
ways will be helpful for you so
let's build off of this rank example
instead so we're going to bring on our
store and we've got store a b c d and e
and then we'll bring on our sales
and store a had ten dollars and e had
forty dollars
so
now let's
create a calculated field
we're gonna call it
rank
we're going to do a rank calculated
field
based on sales
we're going to do a rank calculated
field based on sum of sales
perfect
okay
we'll double click on rank and we can
see first place is the one who had the
most sales and fifth place is the one
with the lease sales now we had a tie
here at 20
and it gave them both third place and
then it skipped fourth place and went to
fifth place and that's how the basic
rank function works
so if we duplicate it
and we edit our copy
and we're going to make this one
rank dense
you know what let's do rank modified
second okay
and we bring on rank modified
let's have this happen in order so sum
of sales then rank then rank modified
now you can see
it's similar to rank first second but
then it skips third and goes to fourth
and then fifth so over here it gave them
higher number
when there was a tie and over here it
gave them the lower number when there
was a tie
so if you could remember that
rank gives them the higher number and
rank modified gives them the lower
number that will be helpful
for your interview
now we're going to take a look at rank
dense
rank dense apply
and rank dense doesn't skip a number so
it goes one two three four and it
condenses
the ranking
without any skipping any numbers
and now let's
do our last one
which is going to be
rank unique
okay
and with rank unique it refuses to give
to
the same rank
and how it determines when there is a
tie is it will look at the dimension
that's in the visualization and do
whichever one comes first in ascii so it
goes one two and these are a tie and
since capital b
comes before
lowercase c
then it's doing b first then c
then a
so in your interview it would be really
impressive to talk about the different
versions of ranks
and how they all work
question 23 how can you embed a web page
in a dashboard so we're just going to
build this and then explain it so i have
here my map by sales and we're going to
build a dashboard
we'll bring on first we'll change our
layout so i can fill up the screen
then let's bring on my map
and i've added the state name and the
sales on the map here
for an embedded web page you can grab it
from the objects section the web page
and then you could put a url right
inside of here
and then that will embed that page
underneath
so if we wanted to do wikipedia or
something we can hit okay and it will
take you to wikipedia
but what we're going to do is make this
page dynamic based on what state you
select it'll look up that wikipedia page
for that state so you could maybe look
at some population data
we'll close that and we'll try again
we're going to bring on our web page
it's going to ask for a url but we're
just going to hit ok and not provide it
with a url
and then we'll use this dashboard action
and create a url action
that then contains our url
with our state
appended at the end which is how
wikipedia formats their url so we'll hit
okay
oh i forgot one more thing let's do it
on select instead of on menu so whenever
we select something it will run this
okay okay and now when we select texas
it brings up the texas wikipedia page
when we select nebraska
it'll change
so the major points to know on how to
embed a web page is you bring it in from
the objects section and then if they ask
how to make it dynamic you use dashboard
actions and a url action
question 24 design a view to show
region-wide profit and sales
so one way you could do this is by
bringing on region and then bringing on
profit and
sales
and that's a pretty simple view of
profit and sales by region however
one thing that interviewers may be
looking for when asking a question about
region
is your mapping capabilities in tableau
so
what we could do
is
region is not a geographic location so
it takes a little bit of creativity but
if you bring on state by double clicking
it and it maps out the states
you can
make it a map here and it fills it in
and then you can bring region onto color
and that splits it up by region
and then if you bring on profit
and sales on the labels
and let's also bring on the state onto
labels
and then you can look at your profit and
sales inside of their regions inside of
their states
and so
that is another view where you could
look at
profit and sales by region
and it's a little bit more
takes advantage of some of the mapping
capabilities in tableau it may be what
your interviewer is looking for so you
could discuss multiple ways to look at
it but here is one way that we could
recommend it question 25 how can you
optimize the performance of a dashboard
there are multiple ways to optimize the
performance of the dashboard some of the
things that you might mention is that
you could exclude any fields you're not
using from your visualization just keep
them off or you can use extract filters
and if you recall extract filters will
remove out rows of data from the extract
and so only focus on the data that you
need another thing you can do is try and
limit the amount of filters that you use
and when you do use filters avoid using
quick filters and you can use action
filters and parameter filters instead
filters cause your queries in the
database to be a little bit more complex
and can keep them from running as
efficiently as they could use min and
max instead of average because average
functions require more processing time
than min and max also you can try to use
boolean and numerical calculations
because computers do better with
integers and booleans than they do with
strings
so quick things to remember is keep your
data simple
use fewer filters and when you do use
filters use parameters or actions avoid
using average use min and max and avoid
using strings by using booleans and
numerical calculations
question 26 which visualization will be
used in the given scenarios here we have
three scenarios of opportunities that
you might want to visualize
and there is no perfectly exact answer
for these but there are some
visualizations that tend better for
certain types of data however there
sometimes could be
different ways to visualize it and it
doesn't mean that these are the very
best ways however if you want to take a
moment go ahead and pause the video and
go through
and figure out what your three answers
are and comment below and we can discuss
what we think the best ways are so first
we want to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of product categories and
subcategories we want to show the
duration of events or activities and we
want to show quarter wise profit growth
so to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of products subcategories
and categories you could use a tree map
the reason we bring up a tree map here
is that they are known for allowing you
to show a visualization
using hierarchies so let's take a look
at that we're going to show aggregated
sales totals across the range of product
categories and subcategories so if we
come here and make a sheet
and we want to see sales across control
click
category and subcategory and then we
click a tree map
what happens
it's showing
it based on size and color and so it
shows the size the bigger the size the
more sales and the darker the color the
more sales and the reason we choose a
tree map over just a normal heat map is
that
it makes a category here so we can
compare this box that has all the
technology in it see how all these are
technology to this box that has all of
the office supplies and you can quickly
see that technology
has more than office supplies but you
can also see that phones has more than
art and it breaks it up as a hierarchy
and breaks it up based on your sum of
sales and question two is show duration
or events a duration of events or
activities and you would use a gantt
chart gun charts are used to show
duration
and each of these lines
is a duration so it's like it's got a
start date and end date basically and it
shows you how long everything takes and
the last one is to show
profit growth and you can use a
waterfall chart and that looks like
this where you can see how the profit
changes across every period and if it's
going up or down
and each one of these show you how much
up or how much down they go but as we
said there are potentially other answers
to this question so
if you have any questions about why we
didn't say this chart or that chart go
ahead and comment below and we can start
a discussion question 27 what would you
do if some countries or provinces or any
geographical entity is missing and
displaying a null when you use map view
so when you start to map the
geographical fields that you have
sometimes tableau is unable to map them
because their locations are unknown or
ambiguous meaning a lot of states have a
city called springfield and i won't know
where to draw that city so for example
let's look at
here so we've taken city as our detail
and it's drawn a lot of cities however
it's got a lot of unknown values here so
if this question comes up you've got to
remember these three things
you can edit locations filter the data
or show data at default position
edit locations allows you to correct the
locations by putting in their unique
names i'll show you an example of this
filter the data means just keep them off
of the view and show data default
position means show it at 0 0 on the map
so edit locations
here we can say here's all of these
cities that seem to exist
in multiple locations and we could say
well we know what state they're in as
well and that should help you answer the
question so you can choose a field that
will define the state so here we're
saying the state is from the state field
and we hit okay
and then it can draw the rest of those
cities
sometimes you want to keep them off
perhaps maybe they spelled city names
wrong and you just want to exclude those
and the last one is show data at default
position
which is 0 0. 28 what is a level of
detail expression
a level of detail expression or an lod
expression is maybe the way they will
present it to you and lod stands for
level of detail so obviously it helps
you get to the level of detail that you
want in your visualization but it also
is used to run complex queries at the
data source level instead of all in the
tableau interface
so we're going to take a look at an
example here which is adding a dimension
to an already
calculated aggregate field
in our case we're going to exclude a
dimension from a calculated field so
here we have
a visualization that i built and right
now it's just looking at sales by
category and subcategory but say we
wanted to look at the total sales for
furniture
and not break it up by the subcategory
so if we take off subcategory
then we get the total sales for
furniture but if we want a side by side
and so that you could see the total
sales for furniture and you can see
it broken up by subcategory you can use
a level of detail calculation
this i already made the field for it
i've called it exclude subcategory so
that's right here
right now it just contains sales
but we're going to use the level of
detail calculation exclude
and we're going to tell it what to
exclude which is subcategory and then
we're going to do
sum
of sales so that it will sum it up for
us
and once i apply these changes it should
change it here and our labels
perfect so now we can see that it's
ignoring the fact that this is chairs
and this is tables this is bookcases
it's just doing the total for furniture
and just ignoring these because we told
it to exclude so level of detail helps
you to be able to define the level that
you want to in your visualization
regardless of what else exists on your
visualization
it also moves some of the logic from
inside of tableau to the actual database
and there are three level of detail
calculations this will be an important
thing to bring up in interviews they
might give you brownie points when you
can remember all three of the level of
detail calculations which are
we looked at exclude
but we have
exclude
include
and
fixed
so include exclude are pretty easy to
remember and just always remember fixed
as well question 29 how do you calculate
daily profit measure using level of
detail here's another opportunity for
you to pause the video and take a look
at calculating a daily profit measure
using level of detail we are going to
get started
profitable level of details so
we want to have a daily profit measure
and i already made a place for it profit
per day
and we want to look at the profit for a
day regardless
of what else is on the visualization so
we're going to use a fixed
instead of an include or an exclude
which will only take into account
whatever you put in for include or
exclude fixed will take into account
everything it will ignore everything
else on the visualization and only look
at what's in your list here so we're
going to fix it by day
and you have to put a colon
and we're going to do a sum of profit
for each of those days
and close it off so now we have our
profit per day we'll hit ok and now
we're going to make a kpi
which for our purposes if profit for a
day is greater than 2000 then that day
is highly profitable if it's less than
zero then it's unprofitable otherwise it
is profitable so we're gonna go if
our profit per day
is greater than two thousand
then
we're going to call it highly profitable
elsif
we're going to do less than or equal to
then
profitable
else
otherwise it is profitable
you always have to end with an end
great
okay
so now we're going to make
some visualizations and it's going to
look at it by year
now it all fits in one view
we um
can rotate these labels to make it
easier to see and we're going to bring
on
order id
but now it's showing like a lot of
orders and so we actually want it to be
used as a measure and we're going to do
account distinct
great so now we can see how many orders
we're on each day
and so that's helpful for us to see how
many orders are on this day each day but
we want to see
the orders on each day that are highly
profitable versus unprofitable versus
just profitable so we're going to use
our level of detail
and break it up in a different section
so we have highly profitable profitable
and unprofitable let's also bring this
on to our color
highly profitable profitable and
profitable and now we can see
that the profitable ones are going up
unprofitable ones seem to be going down
in 2015 and that's nice but they are
going up and highly profitable is not
very many
oh in this case we did area charts
instead of just line charts to make that
change you change it from automatic to
area and that helps you see some of that
spatially as well comment below if you
were able to make this visualization on
your own
question 30 how can you schedule a
workbook in tableau after publishing it
so when you publish a workbook in
tableau if you've used an extract you're
going to need to refresh that extract so
in tableau when you create a tableau
data source and it's an extract version
of the data source it will no longer
update if the data from your database
updates so somebody's made some changes
to your database or your excel file and
you want to see that in your tableau
visualization well you're not going to
see it but you can see it if you make a
refresh so you do that on tableau server
and you can remember that you have to
get all the way to your data source so
you can go to your data sources or to
your workbooks
and then you look at the data source on
your workbook and you go actions extract
refresh and then you select schedule a
refresh so that looks like this you can
press these three dots next to it and
click refresh extracts or you can go to
actions and then here you click schedule
a refresh instead of refresh now and
then oftentimes in tableau you'll have
several different options you can choose
daily at seven a.m or every four hours
if an interviewer is asking you
about how to schedule a refresh it might
be worthwhile bringing up the fact that
you only need to schedule a refresh if
you are
using an extract on your data source and
then that will help them know that you
know the difference between live and
extracts if they didn't ever ask that
question thank you michelle for that
really great session with that we've
reached the end of this complete tableau
tutorial i hope you guys enjoyed the
video do like and share it thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]